for the benefit of the audience we're
just waiting for a couple more members
to arrive since it's an executive
session we do do need all everyone
present before we can proceed so just
give us a few more
minutes
e
good morning everyone and welcome to the
house committee on Health and Human
Services and elderly Affairs as noticed
we have several uh bills to consider an
executive session this morning uh before
we get to those however I'd ask you to
please join me in the Pledge of
Allegiance pledge allegiance to the flag
of the United States of America and to
the Republic for which it stands one
nation under God indivisible with
liberty and justice for
all thank you
everyone um a couple of the bills will
be taking
uping either one 1669 yes
um the first two first two bills that
will be considered this morning and we
we we'll actually switch the order
around a little bit and start off with
HP 1669 FN because they're both early
bills they both have to go to a second
committee um I would I would point out
to everyone here uh who may be making
motions this morning and who will be
responsible for the um reports for the
um uh bills for which they make the
motion uh whatever that motion ends up
being and whatever passes or whether
it's recomend no recommendation or
whatever I do need all the committee
reports today um so we can get them in
the calendar uh and and going forward um
speaker's office has admonished all of
the committee chairman that all reports
need to be done the day of the Motions
um you know and the executive sessions
being held so um we have representative
n here from leadership that will report
back that I made that announcement right
representative n you you'll you'll let
the speaker know I made that
announcement okay thank
you all right all right thank you um so
with that I will open up the floor and
again let's just reverse the order a
little bit and start off with HB 1669 FN
and um so representative
Merchant thank you Mr chair pres
um I submit to the committee for their
consideration
Amendment
9h I wanted to thank the I'll second
that oh thank you would you like to
speak to your motion thank you Mr
chairman I'm a strong supporter of
personal privacy I think that's
something we take dearly here in the
state of New
Hampshire and I think what I'm trying to
do is amend the bill for
clarification in working with both
the represent Lon and also the
Department of Health Human Services I
think this finds that Sweet
Spot currently the department does not
share data within the registry now so
that's really not an issue it's going
forward what we do second changes the
terminology from data to
information in talking with the
Department I came across the fact that
something called personally identifiable
information which is different then Phi
which is patient health information
patient health information is defined by
Hippa
this is a terminology used a lot in
cyberspace or into technology and so
forth so it's more broader if you will
but it's clear to what we're trying to
accomplish and
thirdly what I wanted to be sure of is
that if a provider goes into the
registry whether it be a school
nurse practitioner pharmacist whoever go
into the registry that if they extract
the information from the data to put it
into the medical record on behalf of the
patient that is not included with
restrictions um it becomes very
difficult and owners some if you
basically want to have every single
provider who's ever take anything out of
the registry to have them go back and go
through their records to to remove it so
therefore I want to be clear that this
does not apply to a provider who takes
information out of the registry as far
as the ability for the state when they
go into any kind of sharing of
information we currently have the same
situation with the prescription duck
monitoring program
our state law is very clear who can have
access to that data it's medical records
the prescription data if the state wants
to share that data with another state
they have to ensure that that state will
abide by our state laws and that in fact
is what happens in that program as well
so whenever they have a contract with
another state to share the data that
state has to comply with our state laws
so I think this is a sweet spot is
trying to find a way to protect privacy
at the same time allow
access thank you representative Lon uh
thank you Mr chairman and thank you very
much representative Merchant for um
taking the lead on getting this
amendment I really appreciate everything
that you do in order to Value personal
privacy and everything to support people
here in the state and I really thank you
for your work on this um I'm going to
support this obviously and I think this
will be great to move forward and just
make sure that that we're removing a
potential for concern from people and
ensuring that our data will be handled
correctly so thank you other
discussion representative
Shapiro thank you Mr chairman um I also
appreciate um the two Representatives
working on this together to get a
compromise that um hopefully we can
support um I'm just curious um there was
an on the initial bill there was a
financial note of $3 million and then
that was amended and
um I believe this is the case reduced
to 160 to
$180,000 for fiscal year 2025 and then
$100,000 so I'm curious with the
amendment is this fiscal note
still likely
accurate um thank you representative Sor
um thank you it should be accurate
because this is just specifying that
language um that was in order to have
somebody work at the department in order
to make sure sure that these that um we
do have the correct data entry sections
um this is ear bill so it's headed off
to finance off to finance but we have
removed that $3 million charge through
both the prior Amendment and this one so
I think it's been a good
move you all set representative follow
um I I would
just I'm going to vote for this because
I appreciate the fact that um people are
working together to um protect private
um but I'm also aware of uh um what was
said on the floor last week about the
limited amount of money that's going to
be available for um Finance
to um appropriate for all these things
that are coming forward and um this
would likely not be my
priority representative Lon um thank you
Mr chairman um I I recognize that we
have limited funds um because we are not
sharing and we are not in the process of
entering into any contracts at this
point I think that that fiscal Noe is
actually premature for spending in this
year whenever we do look to um to agree
to contract in order to share that
information in the future there will be
a cost to it there may be I assume that
there will be this additional cost when
we do make that choice and put this out
um for the contracts but until we make
that choice to share the data externally
with with other states or other bodies
then I don't expect that we'd be
spending that
money thank you for that clarification
representative Merchant to follow up on
representative Lon um thank you for the
question representative Sho my
understanding is because we're not
currently sharing data there's no change
that has to occur within the department
so therefore there's no need for fiscal
funds however if the department elects
to share or want to share data with
another state and therefore have to be
sure that things are in place and so
forth at that point in time it would
require some fiscal funds to do it so
currently based upon the way the
amendment's written there should be no
impact financially to the state however
if the department wanted to do something
they would have to come back and asked
for the
funds other
discussion seeing none okay with that a
motion is ought to pass on Amendment
2024 hyphen 0619 H to House Bill 1669 FN
I'll ask the clerk to call
R representative Lon yes representative
kushman yes representative Bill King yes
representative kofalt yes representative
McAn
yes representative Seth King
yes representative Missour
yes representative Nagel yes
representative ner yes representative
Weber
yes representative McKay yes
representative fedus yes representative
Canon yes representative Nutter upam
yes representative Shapiro
yes representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy
yes representative priest
yes representative Tazz yes and
represent McDonald yes 20 to
zero good wait
okay do I have a motion on hb1 1669
FN yes I'll make a motion
to op to pass as amended on House Bill
1669 FN second representative Le on
seconds uh does do either of you wish to
speak to that
motion does anyone wish to speak to that
motion okay when the clerk is ready I'll
ask him to call a roll a motion is ought
to pass as amended on HB 1669 FN
representative Lan yes representative
Bill uh sorry representative kushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative kofalt yes yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Missour yes
representative
Nagel representative Nel not in the room
okay
representative ner
yes representative Weber yes
representative McKay
yeah representative fedus yes
representative Canon yes representative
Nutter
upam representative Shapiro
yes representative Merchant
yes representative Murphy yes
representative priest
yes representative tez
yes representative McDonald yes 20 Z to
one I'm sorry 19 19 zero and one not
voting Mr chairman yes representative
Weber um I'm wondering about consent
there's no appropriation to the bill so
and it is going to finance so um there's
no objection my hope is that it could go
on consent sure especially as it's going
to finance next okay yeah if there's no
objection uh Christino do you are we you
okay on that or do you
know you don't okay you were giving me
kind of a look back there so I wasn't
sure okay if there's no objection we'll
put we'll put that on
consent okay next up is uh HB 1593 FN
okay representative Shapiro you have an
amendment I
believe yes I do yes I
do so I would move or to pass or I would
move adopting
Amendment 0416 on House Bill 1593 and
I'll pass it
around okay I'll give it a moment to
make it around before we get into any
discussion did I do I have a second on
that representative Weber seconds and
while it's making its way around
representative Shapero would you like to
speak to your motion yes so I hope
everybody remembers how many people came
to the hearing to um testify about this
this bill
concerns
um certain kinds of recreational
activities that were previously paid for
through um a CMS waiver for
developmentally disabled people so these
are um these are activities that people
do that are not like going to a
therapeutic dance class for disabled
people but going to regular activities
in the community um to improve people's
um socialization and to improve people's
integration into the community and um
there was a great deal of support and I
think there was a great deal of support
in this committee as well um so since
the hearing um I've been working with
representative Leon and um DHHS and
somebody representing the area agencies
and what we have done with this
amendment is um number one we have
reduced the original appropriation from
a million to
$500,000 we have also taken out um
making this a Permanent Fund so this
will not be a Permanent Fund this will
be a stop Gap
measure um to fund these Services until
the next budget cycle when this will be
addressed um in a more integrated way
with other changes
um those are the two major changes that
we've made
um so um this is a bill that um the
Department of Health and Human Services
I've been working with attorney namoth
has supported um it's got to go to
finance committee where it'll face the
same hurdles as I was just talking about
with the last bill which is that there
are limited funds and um a lot of
Appropriations are heading there um but
I think this is something that we can
support um that
will support developmentally disabled
people being able to have a full life in
the community and um um they've had it
before this was um either a change in
CMS rules or or a newly new
interpretation of CMS rules that made it
so that all of a sudden they couldn't be
paid for so I would ask you to support
adopting Amendment
0416 okay thank you other
discussion representative Lon um thank
you Mr chairman and uh thank you
representative Shapiro for all the work
you've put into this
I think that it's absolutely critical
that we make sure that these services
are restored um and I think that it's
actually most important that we restore
it first to those people who were
already receiving these funds previously
because we already know that those
people had these programs they knew how
to do it they had already been vetted
and approved through their area agencies
and so the idea of addressing them first
and then handling anything else that
will require a little bit more work to
get those approved and get those paid
for I think would be a strong stronger
path forward to make sure that we're
restoring those funds as quickly as we
possibly can um I think that it's been
an absolute travesty that um the way
that this whole shakeup that came from
the federal government has impacted this
really important really special
community that we need to make sure that
we are all supporting um has been just
terrible but we also need to make sure
that those people who are already
receiving services are the ones who are
first restored so um I I really
appreciate as far as representative
Shapiro came on this one um but I think
that it's um I I'll have another
amendment to present that um would then
prioritize the people who missed that um
who were already receiving services so
while I appreciate the work it just
doesn't go far enough for me um so thank
you representative Weber um if if we are
going to be asked to
consider the contents of another
amendment as well as this Amendment
would it be possible to have that passed
out um so I already passed that out so I
can change what I said I simply don't
think that this amendment goes far
enough in order to ensure that we're
restoring services so I don't even need
to reference it regardless of whether or
not that other Amendment passes I think
the first thing we need to do is restore
the services to the people who had them
ripped away from them when the federal
government made us change the way we
provide these services to me that is the
critical point and um I don't think that
this amendment goes far enough so I
won't be supporting it thank you
represent Weber understood I'm just
trying to work out for myself the order
in which we're dealing with things the
ability to read what I haven't read yet
and decide
whether um whether I want to support the
one or the other because while I am I
appreciate your point and I in many ways
agree with it I
also um
am rendered very uncomfortable by saying
that we're creating a two-tiered system
here and that's what it sounds like I'm
hearing you saying so I need to read the
bills the the Amendments before I make a
determination CL I vote for
clarification at
06338 right representative Lon correct
and that's the one I handed out before
it's two pages that are stapled together
if you open it up and turn to the second
page um it basically just says that we
prioritize has to be some way in which
all of the cases are handled is it
alphabetically is it by the date
received or is it by the people who have
already receive these
Services representative
Shapiro um I I would like to speak to
the two amendments if I can I don't um I
don't really we have a motion on the
floor for one I don't think we can
consider the other at the same
time representative we are the
Parliamentary expert here I I
what we have done what I used to do when
I was chairing was I would have them
both handed out I would discuss both of
them before I take a motion we have a
motion um committee procedure is very
very loose as you know and there are
very few guidelines for it I certainly
have no objection if nobody else does if
if we allow reference to both while
people are trying to make up their minds
on the one before us I don't see any
better way of coming to a properly
reasoned conclusion so uh while it may
not
be just seems sensible to me that we
should be able to consider and and speak
about the merits of both because I think
they both do have Merit all right I
proceed representative shapo okay so if
you have both amendments in front of you
one is 0416 that's the amendment where
there's a motion um and then there's 0 6
33h which is the um amendment that um
representative Leon has sponsored and
has um just discussed and um you take my
word for it without reading it they're
exactly identical except on page two
lines one and two of Representative
Leon's Amendment those that line is
added the Department of Health and Human
Service shall prioritize payment for
service provided to July prior to July
1st 2023 that were reduced or excluded
from payment after such date other than
that they're identical
um I have been working with the
Department of Health and Human Services
to make sure that we have everybody on
board so I was absolutely fine when um
representative Leon's
um amendment was when I saw
representative Le Leon's Amendment
um I don't think prioritization is
necessary but I don't think it makes any
practical difference I think there's
enough money appropriated that anybody
who um deserves and you know it's it's
clinically determined that they need
these um services will get them so I
don't think there's a practical
difference however in working with the
various parties um I was told by
attorney namoth at Department of Health
and Human Services that
um they couldn't support that language
so so therefore I think that we should
and and she is present if we want to
hear from her um so therefore my
priority is number one to get um as full
of support as possible from this
committee so that it go forth to finance
committee where they'll look at it again
um and that could be either Amendment
but I think it makes sense for us to go
to to put this forward with an amendment
that DHHS can support because I think
that in the long run that will give us
the best chance of it um becoming
statute and people getting these
services so those are the two
distinctions I don't know if we want to
hear from um attorney nth about what the
particular issue is with those two lines
or not I will leave that up to the
chair I would represented Weber I would
find it helpful if we could have a very
brief statement from
attorney attorney
namoth uh good morning Mr chairman
members of the committee for the record
my name is Melissa nth I'm an attorney
with the Department of Health and Human
Services
and the there were a couple of concerns
that the the department had with the
language um added by representative Lyon
in her Amendment and one is the
reference to the date July 1st
2023 um that's factually incorrect as
that there was a lot of work that was
done with a corrective action plan that
caused a lot of change to the
developmental Services system as of July
1st
2023 this issue is completely
independent of that um it is something
that had come up throughout waiver
amendments uh and so that that date just
isn't correct and so that that is part
of the concern the department had um and
also based on the language that was
received from CMS as to whether these
Services should be included in the
waiver or not and having this language
here um the department feels that having
a language of this nature in in a
statute has the potential
to have
CMS take another look at this um and
there's a that could be the potential
for some action on their part of course
no one knows if that would be uh taken
or not but the department just wanted to
point those two items out um for the
committee's consideration and again as
was stated at the previous hearing the
department is completely supportive of
the concept of of this bill and ensuring
that folks you know do have access to
Services representative Lon um thank you
Mr chman and thank you for providing
this I'm sorry I wasn't able to meet up
with you prior to discuss this but I
think it benefits the committee as a
whole um does CMS prevent the state from
choosing how to spend State funds to
support people here no this is this
would only be with respect to CMS only
has a say with respect to those on the
waiver so has a followup followup and so
as a followup if CMS has no say about
how we spend our state funds why would
spending State funds to cover something
that the CMS has said is no longer
coverable with CMS funds cause problems
with us with CMS so the risk is that the
the way in which these were provided
previously what what the state has been
told by CMS is that these were never
supposed to be provided on the waiver
yet they were for a number of years um
CMS has expressed a desire to look
forward with the state to look
prospectively on fixing that rather than
looking retroactively and so the concern
is references to there having had been
continued payment on the waiver for
these Services that's where the state
sees there is a potential for um action
on the part of CMS and as I said there's
no way to predict whether or not that
would happen um but that's the
concern another followup as another
followup um I recognize that concern but
I'm just trying to figure out if it's
more important to restore these services
to people who already had them first or
to worry about a potential question from
CMS when they already know that we're
moving forward and trying to get this
done with state only funds and something
else I'd like to point out this wasn't
um as if a curtain came down and
everything stopped these are the being
reviewed as people's service Agreements
are being reviewed so it's being looked
at kind of on a rolling basis um so as
people's service Agreements are coming
up if they had certain services in there
before when that's being renewed with
their team they're looking at it in the
context of what the waiver permits now
um and what CMS has said is allowed a so
it wasn't like I said it wasn't as if a
curtain came down and things stopped
overnight um I know it probably feels
that way to some people who were getting
their services and and went through the
renewal process and maybe have been told
those cannot be covered now um but I
just wanted to provide that
clarification too as to how this has
been
working let other people ask some
questions I might have one after
representative Weber I I actually have a
comment rather than a question so if
anybody else has questions
representative mer you've been very
patient over there thank you Mr
chairperson
a question on
the page two line
one I'm concerned because if you look at
the prior page the department shall
contract with one or more
organizations however then we go back
into page two on line one it will be the
department Health Human Services who
shall
prioritize the payments versus the
organization who's been given the funds
I think it' be problematic because we're
getting into state not having the access
to what was being done yet we're
requiring them to do the prioritization
versus the organization that receives
the funds that's the first thing
secondly I do agree with the fact that
many of these things probably happened
after July 1
2023 and therefore we get into looking
at how we prioritize things so I'm not
opposed to prioritization what I'm
concerned about is the process we put in
place to who's going to do the
prioritization because the way it's
written today the money goes to the
organization
but then the department has to instruct
the organization how to use the funds
when they don't have probably a lot of
the knowledge the agency has on how the
funds were utiliz so it's just a quirk
in the the way it's written
representative land did you want to
respond or um thank you um that's a good
point my question would be how the
department plans to make sure that these
services are first restored to those
people who had them denied and what your
plan is moving forward if we authorize
this without the language to make sure
that these the people who are already
participating in this are the first ones
who received this money so how would you
plan to do that in the department uh I
don't I don't have the subject matter
experts here with me today and I wasn't
prepared for that question so I do
apologize um but I think the department
understands the the question um and I
know in the previous iterations there
were when it was proposed to be uh a
long-standing fund there was a whole
provision about rulle making I think
that would have addressed that so um you
know I can see maybe potentially in the
contract cont with the agency that would
be administering this that kind of
language would be included the
department would include that with with
that vendor so that they knew everyone
kind of knew what the guidelines were
for providing those
Services representative Nagel and then
representative Weber uh thank you Mr
chairman thanks for taking my question
when we originally saw this bill the
dollar figure was a million dollars now
it's
$500,000 and I asked the question back
then do we know exactly what the total
cost of what we're paying out now is do
we know what that number is my
understanding is no um that this is an
estimation and I think it was arrived at
working with a representative from the
area agencies who have the best
knowledge about what is being paid out
and based on a survey of information
that they gave back this was based on
that
estimate follow up so is that number
sufficient to cover everybody or not as
was suggested earlier today the
Department's understanding is that based
on the the information the area agencies
provided that as to what was being paid
out for these services that this figure
would be sufficient to cover those thank
you representative
Weber this isn't a question it's a
comment that I hope might get us further
forward I I'm remembering my French
teacher whose favorite phrase was
Coupe which means uh splitting a hair
into four different parts
and it seems to me that first of all
we're very much on the same page about
what we want to do um and
secondly um looking at it from the point
of view of either of the two amendments
it sounds very much that as best we can
determine the people who have been
receiving
Services could be covered by the
$500,000 um um payment
it sounds further to me like if the
department is having an agency
administer the department does simply
put in the request for proposal or or
the directive or the contract or
wherever it goes because I'm not an
expert on Contracting that
concern uh so I have been this uh
speaking only for myself I have been
talked around into the proposal that I
don't care which one of these two passes
and if if um the second of the two is
the one that would get us to uh 20 to0
rather than 10 to 10 which I think is a
completely uh losing proposition on the
floor of the New Hampshire house and
with the knowledge that it is still
going to finance where as we all know
finance will do things to it that none
of us intended or expected and we'll
have to deal with that at the time um I
I want to just state that I would be
happy with going forward with either of
these
and that's just one person's opinion so
thank you representative uh Murphy thank
you Mr chairman uh just a point of
clarification from my notes I took I
thought that relative to the cost going
from a million to half a million the
people that administer the program
thought that given the fact that it
would start halfway through the year it
would be probably only a quarter of that
as well so even just 250,000 but the
other question I had is in Dr I mean in
representative Leon's uh Amendment um
should on line 19 on page one should
that be June of 2024 because do you know
representative Shapiro mentioned that
these are identical and that's only a
difference in the date so would that be
25 then representative Leon um thank you
that's a great question I actually
wanted to make this effective
immediately and I didn't get the draft
back that had an effective immediately
date because if we're able to get it
through both bodies quickly and get it
signed let's not waste a a month or a
week or anytime getting this money and
getting these Services restored um if I
can ask sure um so my other question is
I want to make sure that we prioritize
this but the language that I had was not
correct uh if and we have a few other
bills to exact um would language along
the lines of contracts to distribute
These funds uh should require the
agencies um to First restore Services
before providing new services
or something similar to that work so
that we can know that what we're trying
to do is get people who already had
something that was approved um get them
taken care of first because it's going
to there's time and resource constraints
on everything if we already know that
you know the gentleman who was in the
bowling league the people who are
already receiving these Services we
already know it's helping so if we can
make sure that that happens first before
we have the resources to figure out
anybody who didn't take have them before
I think that that would be the most
aable one because it's not going to take
much work to reapo what had already been
paid but it will take time for people
who are establishing these these
programs is could there be language
about
that um I think there probably could be
um and you know if there is some
direction to the department I think
what's again what's difficult is these
are coming up as service Agreements are
being renewed so um I don't know if
there is a we the area agency experts
aren't here today um but I think the
department would need to turn to them to
say how because if the department
doesn't know you know if new budget
requests are coming in and they don't
have that it the department wouldn't
necessarily know oh you know this
individual had this before and now they
don't have that in their budget so I
don't know if there's a good way to
gauge that um and the the
agencies have also been turning to their
family support councils in some
instances um who have authority they
they make up their you know they have
some rules they have to abide by but
they have policies and guidelines so
that for some people that were getting
the service it was in their service
agreement it wasn't approved when it was
renewed they've gone to their family
support Council seeking these funding
this funding and in many instances it's
the Department's understanding that the
Family Support councils have approved
that so for some folks there is a
mechanism for which they they have had
some continuity but I it's difficult to
know I don't know that there's a exact
metric to understand who had what and
when and what has changed um but I think
the department would certainly be
amendable to trying to work through that
um and and see what can be done
representative Merchant then
representative Shapiro thank you Mr
chair uh I offer to the committee the
following language the Department of
Health Human Services shall include
language in the contract with the
organization for that organization to
prioritize Services provided prior to
July 1st
2023 representative Lon I think that's
almost there it sounds like the July 1st
2023 but to provide services previously
offer um previously offered uh due to a
service reconsideration previously I I
what would the be the better thing
instead of the July 1st
2023 um maybe I'm trying to think on the
Fly here so pardon me but maybe in the
individualized budget that is what
authorizes the payment for services so
maybe if it was in someone's
individualized budget
previously so previously included in an
individualized
budget is that close enough to get it to
finance I I I you know like I said the
department supports either and the
Department's intention was not to you
know was to provide information so that
people were aware and that if the
department were to raise concerns and a
further committee by full transparency
did not want folks to say well why
didn't you raise that concern earlier um
so that was the Department's intention
in in bringing any concerns forward
representative chapero yes I just want
to remind people that representative
Stringham who is sitting in the back of
the room and representative Edwards um
who came in to inquire about this bill
earlier are the two pro are the two
sponsors of this bill and they are both
on finance 3 and um it will get a you
know a kind of a a a
very thorough um going over when it gets
there so um I think we can make a
decision about which amendment to use
and move forward representative
Weber I'm still in the cutting the hair
in
four uh part I think that what
representative Leon's Amendment does is
Express pretty clearly
what um uh you know the cons takes care
of a lot of the concerns the people had
and while I would prefer the language of
the other one I'm I'm I think that this
does give a sense that what we're trying
to do is fill the Gap first and then if
there's any Splash over that's great and
we've been assured that this probably is
okay the other thing I want to remind
people um and I'm thinking of um
representative McMahon and saying while
we're still young
uh is that this is a temporary fill for
something which uh is now just going to
be a temporary till the end of this
budget cycle and then should be
addressed more comprehensively going
forward by the department uh in in the
next budget request and we hope that
they've heard very clearly our concerns
about the need but my suggestion would
be that perhaps this uh Amendment could
be withdrawn and the other Amendment
could be offered we could vote on it and
send it to finance where there could be
further refinements
if if
necessary yes suggestion representative
Weber is to withdraw the motion in the
second on uh
0416 is that what your suggestion is or
I'm speaking only personally I
understand so representative Lon um
thank you Mr chairman we do have several
other bills in front of us and I did
want to make this effective a upon
passage um the language the
representative Merchant suggested the
Department of Health and Human Services
shall include language and the contracts
with the service providers to prioritize
Services previously included in
individualized budgets and changing it
to effective upon passage shouldn't take
long from OS so if we can withdraw the
motion and then move to another as soon
as it's printed I think we've already
had a lot of our discussion and then
we'd be able to move forward I can send
that along right right now with both of
our names representative Merchant okay
and would you like to be on there as
well representative
Shapiro yes sure and and I will agree to
withdraw my um motion to adopt okay and
the who made the
second okay okay so EXC me
representative
McDonald is it possible to add one more
clarification to to what representative
Lon just referenced in the proposed
amendment I think you said contract with
service providers is it really meant to
be those the the contract that is in
section four of the proposed
Bill yes it is so should I just say in
the contracts to prioritize service or
should I use the language from section
four or I'm wondering if just referring
back to section four so it's clear which
contractors I I the the way you had
worded it gave me pause to think that
people might think it was a contract
with any service provider rather than
what was for administering these funds
thank you and that's why we're
woodshedding this right now so uh
include laying anguage
um let's see um in so and then that
would be in the contracts um designated
in sub paragraph 4 I believe that would
get the committee to where they were
looking to
get thank
you okay so uh the motion has been
withdrawn and the second has been
withdrawn uh if I'm understanding the
the sense of the committee we'll we uh
move on to the next bill and we'll come
back to 1593 shortly it is an early bill
so we do need to take action
today okay so pending the amendment
coming from OS we'll move on to hb1
1393 and and just before we move on Mr
chairman I may um our a researcher has
asked us that if it is at all possible
given uh the
sense I'm sending it right in okay I'm
about to send it over with our names I
was just going to say that that the
sidebar that I had was uh possibly could
the report be written while we're
attending the arrival of the amendment
so that the report can be given and sent
in
um yes I I actually have already I've
already drafted um a report so um I was
trying to think ahead on that one so I
already have language and I'll make sure
it's accurate and correct
and actually if we could be doing the
same thing with 16 69% of merchant
you're doing that one
right uh new time or I don't think it
can be done too too soon but noon time
is acceptable I guess
yeah okay uh anything else on um hb6
FN okay we we'll revisit that shortly HB
1393 do I have a motion
representative Nagel I'd like to make a
motion that this uh HB 1393 isn't
expedient to legislate okay is there a
second I can second that or sorry
representative Weber representative
Weber seconds representative Nagel do
you wish to speak to a motion yes this
is very spontaneous but I will do my
best I'm actually on the State Health
assessment um and initiative committee
we actually had a very long sidebar
discussion on this particular Bill
earlier um just the other day um it's a
very complex process to create that
assessment and that initiative and
there's an awful lot of priorities that
we need to have a fair amount of I hate
to use the word wiggle room but wiggle
room um to decide what are priorities
this is obviously a really important
issue but there's also a lot of other
issues and I think to place this in
statute at or above other things is
inappropriate and that I think we need
to Le let that committee decide what the
priorities are and I already know that
this is a priority
representative
Weber thank you and and thank you
representative Nagel um I just I I agree
and the uh outcome if we were to put it
in statute would be that next year this
committee would have 47 or 78 or 132
other equally concerning conditions that
we would be trying to insert in statute
and the point of the plan is a balance
the point and and I think that if if in
writing the
report um the report writer could
include both how important the committee
members think this issue is and that the
issue has been brought
up uh in front of the commissions that's
the appropriate commission and it's
being taken into
consideration um and I'd be glad to work
with you on that if that's helpful later
um but I I think that uh if the report
States those things it it sort of
clarifies the intent of the committee
this is not a dismissal it's a referral
to the appropriate place and a statement
that uh action has started to be taken
and is is to be
ongoing representative Nagel yeah if I
could just add a followup to this if
you've got nothing better to do I
suggest you look at the website for this
program it's not about individual
diagnosis it's about looking at the
whole person in four different
categories so I would add a factor of 10
to the potential priority list that we
could be dealing with um so but I
appreciate that
statement any other
discussion okay if not I'll ask the
clerk to call the r the motion is itl on
HB
1393 representative Leon yes
representive kushman yes representative
Bill King yes representative kofalt yes
representative mlan yes representative
Seth King yes representative Missour
yes representative Nel yes
representative ner yes representative
Weber yes representative McCay yes
representative fedus yes representative
Canon yes
representative nut upam
yes representative Shapiro
yes representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy yes representative
priest yes representative tez yes and
represent McDonald yes 20 to zero
there's no objection we'll put that on
the consent
calendar okay next up is HB 1581 do I
have a motion
sure representative
Nel I I need a I need a committee report
yes uh sooner the better this morning
noon time shortly thereafter it's not an
early bill but I I would like it
today
okay um 1581 moving on to HB 1581
representative Lon um I'd move a to pass
motion is ought to pass is there a
second I'll second it who said that
representative McLean representative
McLean seconds representative Lon do you
want to speak to your motion um yes
thank you Mr chairman um we heard a lot
about the different characteristics of
cannabis whether it's grown under lights
or under natural light um just like
anything else inputs matter uh just like
if you have a stripped soil or a very
rich living soil you're going to get a
different product um I believe that
allowing them to operate an additional
cultivation location will help them to
make sure that they can have the supply
that's necessary and allowing this to be
a greenhouse I think brings beneficial
uh brings a lot of benefits to us you
know all of these are going to have to
comply with local zoning laws so we're
not stepping on any local control we're
just giving enabling legislation to
allow more options for the cultivation
um and especially given that the whole
landscape may be shifting moving forward
if um adult use um cannabis does become
a factor the more that um we can ensure
that the quality of product and um the
richness of product in the therapeutic
cannabis um is able to take advantage of
all the benefits of natural sunlight and
everything else in order to be um the
best match for people who need cannabis
as medicine as opposed to cannabis as um
something else that I think that that's
going to benefit them and help to keep
this program viable um because in other
states when there's been adult use
legalization in in Vermont the amount of
people using the therapeutic program
actually cut in half because there were
a lot of people who were happy with an
offthe shelf shelf option so the more
that we can support the vibrancy and
offerings of the alternative treatment
centers to best meet the needs of
patients not recreational people I think
that this is good and this is moving
things forward in the
state other discussion representative
Nagel thank you Mr chairman is the proud
number one of a 19 to1 vote on a
somewhat similar bill but quite
different I actually support this bill I
like it that it's under the setting of
people that we know really know what
they were doing I've been to these
centers I see what they do I know how
smart they are they're phds in
Horticulture they're amazing people and
um I think this is a great solution for
a very very difficult problem because
these atc's I think are struggling a lot
more than we think they
are other discussion representative mlan
yeah thank you Mr chair I I think how
you know we're almost 10 years in with
this program there were a lot of
security concerns up front before we
knew a lot we've had an opportunity to
see how those are manifested in other
states such as Maine so I I don't think
there there's a real deep concern on the
security side but also from the
perspective of cost um while we have a
very good product in New Hampshire
cost-wise um we're not as competitive
and so setting up an operation that will
help drive down the cost
makes it competitive and drives people
towards a legal Market um so I that
helps with harm reduction and other
things so I I think this is a good
bill representative
Missour thank you Mr chair um I'm
struggling with this one honestly uh and
I I put in my notes and I remember it
from um the hearing is that the analysis
the word
second kind of contradicts the word the
being used used in the actual bill
language of additional the word second
is very different to the word additional
um and so that was my concern then and I
do recall law enforcement uh letting us
know that they were not in favor of this
U because of how it would be hard to
manage for them so I'm I'm honestly
struggling with this one just full
transparency um but those are my two
concerns with it okay thank you other
discussion I seeing none I'll ask the
clerk to call the r the motion is ought
to pass on HB
1581 representative Lon yes
representative kushman
yes representative Bill King
no representative cofal yes
representative mlan yes representative
Seth King
yes representative Missour
no
representative Nagel
yes representative ner
yes representative Weber
yes representative McKay
yes representative fedus
yes representative Canon
yes representative nut upam
yes representative Shapiro
yes representative
Merchant
yes representative Murphy
yes representative
priest yes representative
tez
yes representative McDonald
yes
18-2 and I'm fine with consent okay any
objection if we put on on the consent
calendar okay and Mr chairman did I miss
on uh 1393 did we put that one on the
consent calendar because it was 20 yes
we did okay I missed that thank
you okay next up is uh HB 1706
FN and I understand there may be an
amendment to that yes representative
Phillips is uh is pushing is bringing
this one around um with this um I think
we need to take a look at it and see
where we are um if we're not fully
satisfied with what we have let's get
some constructive comments and see what
we need um and and figure out how to
move forward with us if NE if if that's
the will of the committee okay we'll
take a look at the amendment is it ex
exactly and I apologize for speaking
before being recognized and before we
had the bill in front of us wasn't me
need to jump the
gun which
Bill 1706 thank
you thank you
she hasn't actually made a motion yet
actually and if you'd like I can move
Amendment and I'll tell you the number
in just a second um Amendment 2024
05778 Z second second representative
kushman
seconds and as it gets around we'll let
everybody take a look um and then my
question would be um to the chairman um
the prime sponsor of the bill had worked
on this um Amendment and the question
would be if we would want her to walk us
through what changes were made so that
we can understand because uh this this
was a pretty big change in the bill so I
defer to the chairman on that
okay get it get the amendment fully
around and give it people a moment and
then representative Phillips will be
welcome to come to the witness
table question Mr chair oh yes
representative K is it normal that um we
would ever be given just like 5 minutes
time to just silently read something
because sometimes when somebody's
speaking you want to listen to them but
you also want to read it for yourself
and I can't do the both at the same time
so is that normal to do that something
like that uh it's Case by case there's
no formal procedure on that but if if we
want a couple three minutes to read this
through first I I would second um his
motion sure yeah let's take a moment to
read this through and then when you know
when let me know when you're ready and
then we'll ask representative Phillips
to come forward how does that work is
that aable to everybody
yep
how's everybody
doing anybody who needs more time
or no no go ahead if you need some more
time then go
ahead
Al sir
representative yeah representative PHS
if you'd like to walk us through this
amendment thank you all for for this and
for reading the amendment um
representative Emily Phillips Rockingham
7 Fremont New Hampshire so I went back
and I watched the you know two and a
half hours on this um hearing and I took
in all of the um feedback and I just
heard a lot that the original bill was
overwhelming a little bit redundant so I
trimmed down basically the original Bill
I'm not sure if you have copies of the
original one it's probably hard to
determine what was cut but everything
that was removed from the original bill
I can go through what was changed but
the only thing that was added was one
condition that is a complication so um I
have my Google doc that I sent
um the major changes was the original
Bill asked to show parents considering a
circumcision the restraint board and
some um tools used for the procedure and
instead we switched it out with an image
of so that the um providers didn't have
to re sanitize a restraint board or have
one dedicated just to show parents prior
to the um procedure I removed
[Music]
um uh no health care provider shall
solicit any parent for circumcision
procedure that was originally in there
um there was a 25-year Clause asking the
hospitals to hold on to the original
consent form for 25 years I remove that
from what I'm hearing EMR um records are
forever so that was
unnecessary um I removed a sentence that
said uh since the normal physiological
condition for boys to have non-
retractable foreskin prior to puberty
and often until late teenage years
Healthcare Providers shall not use a
diagnosis of fimosis in order to solicit
a
circumcision I changed um circumcision
is associated with between 20 and 47
known complications I took that out and
just said many cuz who's going to argue
how many known complications there are I
added in Buried penis syndrome into a
reason I'm sorry a um a uh injury after
a circumcision or a condition that can
be caused by circumcision buried penis
syndromes in there um I took out the
statement which I thought was personal
uh your son may want an intact penis and
decision to have a circumcision denies
him his body integrity and autonomy
which he may resent when he matures I
took that out because obviously
it's already kind of suggesting that
this is not medically
necessary
um I took out the section it was a large
section that said there is no proven
medical benefits following newborn
circumcision uh because I think that is
um disputed that there may be a small
medical I'm not sure so I took all that
out because it was just carry-on and
redundant uh the actual medical need for
circumcision in adults is as low as six
in 100,000 guess again you can't put in
statistics there because it could change
over time right
um um took out the non-surgical options
for alternative prophylactics
prophylactics and treatment of potential
problems are those that are tissue
sparing receiving this consent form does
not mean the circumcision is recommended
parents May free CH free freely choose
to not circumcise their son by
withholding signature and returning the
form unsigned that's redundant so I took
that out and then um I took out the
other section um lastly that said prior
to approving circumcision consent forms
and intact care guides the department
shall provide copies of such forms at no
cost to register nonprofit advocacy
organizations again we we took that out
that was redundant and then I changed
the uh effective date from 60 days to
January 1st 2025 because I'm assuming
this is going to take some time to get
get everybody on board so that's the
gist I mean I know it's a lot to
um talk about and consider but I think
that it was overwhelmingly clear that
informed consent is not happening
consistently and that people want it in
New Hampshire so thank you for your time
and consideration of the amendment
representative Seth King thank you Mr
chair uh thank you for taking questions
and doing all this work um maybe I
missed it on line 22 you have uh section
F there solicitation the
definition um but I'm not seeing any
corresponding language in the bill
regarding solicitation um what's the
point of having the definition if
there's if it's not later referred to to
or is it referred to when I just missed
it that's a that's a great catch because
I did remove that but yeah
okay I see another hand up um
representative Shapiro did you have a
hand up that was The Identical question
that I was going to ask okay two minds
of the same direction other
questions representative Seth King again
I'm not sure if this question should be
directed to the one testifying or the
committee in general um but I'm just
curious um maybe the doctors in in the
house can help me uh understand this is
it normal to put informed consent
language in
statute um and if not when we do have
informed consent
mandates who do we trust to write the
informed consent language when it's
mandated so we put a mandate something
needs to be informed consent who are we
trusting to write that language if it's
not in the statute thank you
representative Nel since I just got
handed 15 different informed consents
that I've written in the past that I
need to re-review and have back to our
um um institution in the next three days
I feel very compelled to answer that
question um I've written dozens of
informed consents in my career
historically way back when I started it
was just me I did it but nowadays you
have to go through an Institutional
review group they have to okay it make
sure it's legally acceptable things like
that to actually put an in informed
consent of this type in statute doesn't
happen this would be extremely unique
and um I'll leave my comments on that
practice for
later representative kushman thank you
Mr chairman um there are some uh
informed consent requirements uh that
I've come across in in statutes and
administrative rules particularly the
one that um stands out to me now but I
know that I've seen others um are the
requirement for vaginal bursts after
cesarian section um in the Midwifery
rules so there are some but they do
um
they they defer
to the department to make the form so
the the department does create the form
just like this one um and their
guidelines they defer they basically the
provider gives a information sheet
that's written by the New England um
Quality neonatal Network I think is what
it's called probably not probably
butchered it but um they give the the
fact sheet Pro that an organization
creates and then the department has the
consent form that is printed and and the
patient has to sign and is returned
uh representative Weber and then
representative
Nagel I was just going to point out the
difference between being in statute and
being in rules
um the statutes are created by us
lawmakers and yes we have a few docs and
we have some advanced practice nurse
practitioners and some other people with
very good qualifications but most of us
don't have any of those qualifications
and the point of Ru making is to
delegate to those people who have
significantly more
knowledge uh the creation of um forms
that might
be um that that need specialized
knowledge in order to create
them however that said I'm still I still
have a problem with the actual drafting
of the Lang language of a consent form
the specific language because things
change and sometimes it's quicker to
change a statute than it is to change
rule um if if if the legislature has
guidelines then that's one thing uh but
to actually put specific language
in uh in any case I think for me is a
deal breaker or at least I haven't seen
one yet that I would agree was the right
way to
go representative Neland then
representative play thank you Mr
chairman you pretty much said almost
everything I wanted to say um the only
thing that I would add as part of being
in this job I had the very unpleasant
job of looking through most of the
medical rules and I'm not aware that
there's any informed consent
specifically in the medical on Board of
Medicine rules um what they do refer to
is to the a guide of Ethics is to how
you create and the requirement that you
do use an informed
consent representative Lon and then
representative
Merchant as well um thank you Mr
chairman um I think informed consent
actually is a really important core part
of this decision there's two different
methods of informed consent there's
provider Centric informed consent where
you need to tell the person what a
provider thinks they need to know then
there's patient Centric informed consent
where you need to tell the person what
the patient wants to know sometimes
those aren't the same and it's actually
a really really big difference because
uh we're we're moving towards sort of a
more um homogenized medical system one
where there's more focus on herd
management than individuals and that's
an actual term so I'm not trying to be
uh trying to be rude by saying that but
that's actually one of the terms that's
used in some of of the literature and as
you move away from a patient specific
informed consent if there is more of a
standardization and a deference to
experts there's a really big chance that
people in the state will be harmed I
think that it's actually really
important for us to try and work forward
towards this we probably can talk some
more but I I'd be willing to withdraw my
motion of the amendment and then maybe
suggest that um anybody who wants to
work on it I'd be happy to to talk to
people we can figure out if it should be
a subcommittee or if I should sort of do
this ad hoc with people um but I think
that patient Centric informed consent
especially for something like this is
key I was in the room with all three of
my sons I have a feeling that may not
have been three if my husband had been
in the room so thank you representative
Merchant and then representative
Murphy thank you Mr
chairman there's a couple of concerns I
have with the amendment if you go to
page two on line
it talks about a religious circumcision
in a non-medical
facility many times you may have a
person doing a religious ceremony inside
of the medical facility so that could
occur and right now that would not be
allowed um you can have the rabbi going
to the hospital to do it there versus
doing it outside of the facility so
that's a concern I have number two on
line 25 page two the department has no
jurisdiction over licy that's the Board
of Medicine the Board of Pharmacy the
Board of Nursing they're the ones that
have the jurisdiction over that license
not the department themselves number
three if you look at lines 16 through
22 if you have a situation where you
have two
parents in two different households
known as a
divorce who rules because you could have
one parent who wants to do it as
physical custody of the child in medical
care of that child but the other parent
for whatever reason opposes it just to
be what if you will that is not dealt
with here uh that means you have to go
to the court and try to figure out who
has jurisdiction over this which is a
problem number three or four I do think
that it's important that the
parents have the appropriate education
not the consent
form it's the education that's critical
here not so much that they signed a
consent form so I'd be more than glad to
work with representative Lon to try to
find ways to thread the needle to
achieve what we're trying to achieve
that parents first and foremost have the
knowledge to make the appropriate
decision and also if you look at on the
page most of what's here is all about
the risk and it's very negatively
written and when you get into the
consent
form if I was to read something like
that I'll tell you if you read a package
insert and a drug you would never take
another one in your entire life that's
why we have medical providers to help us
understand what language is that's put
into the package insert for a
drug this is kind of the same thing
where all of a sudden you have a
situation where you hear all the
negative things about whatever it is and
nothing about the positive side so I
think for those reasons it needs to be
amended I think we need to work on it
collectively and I'd be more than glad
not more than glad I'd be willing
I'm already on too many things now but
I'll be willing to work with um Lon or
anyone else on the committee Mr chairman
um to try to find a way to thread the
needle representative Murphy and then
representative Nagel thank you Mr
chairman I'm not sure we're in the asked
the presenter questions yet or just
discussed but I I wasn't going to ask a
question I was going to make a comment
more than anything else and um I I would
say that over the last 40 plus years I
have probably obtained over 10,000 at
least at least 10,000 consents I would
say in that period of time I've probably
used over 10 or so different consent
forms and every one of them was a
generic form informed consent with a
between a provider or surgeon or even if
you're given an injection in the office
is between the provider surgeon in my
case with the patient it's a
conversation it's probably the only
conversation that really keeps you out
of the courtroom if something goes wrong
so I totally and fully embrace the
concept of informed consent I think that
put in any language in Statue or into
rules especially if you try to make up a
specific surgical consent for every
procedure that we do is going to be
terribly problematic it's a very Dynamic
you know process informed
consent things change as I said before I
used over 10 different consent forms in
my career and over 10,000 I'm sure that
I've gotten myself um I I I find it hard
to imagine why in this procedure
specifically we would want to actually
have to show them images of tools that
we use or you know even bring the tools
in certainly it's an improvement to show
an image but certainly it's terribly
problematic to even do that and the
reason I say that having done a number
of procedures over decades these
procedures change often times and if you
were to do say a total knee replacement
or total hip the instruments that we use
change dramatically the implants that we
use change dramatically
and to put in the quest to put into
statute or into any of these form
informed consents images showing the
tools that we use I'm sorry I I I would
find that I would probably say that the
majority or not the majority a large
number of patients who would otherwise
benefit tremendously from a joint
arthoplasty meaning replacement would be
scared to death if I showed them the
instruments that were used that looked
like they come from a hardware store so
you know drills saws cement glue you
know processes that we use the weight of
the processes that we use these are all
incredibly difficult to show a patient
and then get really a truly informed
consent so I I have a very hard time
understanding at all putting informed
consent language into statute or into
rules because of the Dynamics of it
because of the complexity of an informed
consent and because it is probably
something that we do and we take as a
very important part of our conversation
with any patient to try to inform them
as best we can because I can guarantee
you that in all the informed consents I
got I could never ever have included
comprehensively every potential risk or
benefit that they may perceive that they
have or that they encountered during a
procedure so I I would find this
terribly problematic in any way shape or
form to do this especially um the
informed consent part of it thank you
thank you representative Nagel and then
representative Weber thank you Mr
chairman um I'm just going to be blunt
and say that there is no way I would
support the amendment or the bill with
that said what they did that was really
important was bring up this whole notion
of informed consent I really
appreciate the discussion that
representative merch and representative
Lon have come up and I do want to point
out the whole concept informed consent
and the doctor patient
relationship has changed dramatically in
my 35 years and your 40 years when we
started it was basically you know we
dictated to the patient what he did and
they did it without question it's not
like that anymore we use a mutual
consent uh participation model now and
what's really scary fun and everything
at the same time is I swear patients
come in now and they know more about
what I'm doing than I do and our
discussions have gone from me informing
them as the risks and benefits to me
discussing information and
misinformation on what they know and
it's to me that's really exciting but
it's the way things are right now and I
think that we need to seriously sit down
as a group and I'm not sure this
legislation is the right way to do it
but I think we really do need to sit
down have a vehicle and talk about where
we're going with informed consents in
the future because I I I don't disagree
with their point that it's flawed right
now and I think we can make it a lot
better but I don't think that this
legislation for a specific thing is the
right way to do it and with that said I
have three pages of talking points of my
concerns about this bill so I don't want
to bore you with that but um I do think
that that recom suggestion was an
incredibly good one representative
Weber I I was going to just say that I
think um the the one thing that I talk
about people who know a little bit about
everything and come and tell docs about
it but the the thing that I was really
interested to learn recently and a
conversation about this bill is of
course something that had not occurred
to me I'm not a parent so I haven't done
any of this stuff um but the OBGYN who
is the person who is treating the mom
through her pregnancy is often not the
person who is doing the surgery on the
Infant and it is the surgeon doing the
surgery on the Infant who must obtain
the informed consent because I was
thinking you know we just need to make
people focus on talking about this
earlier which I think is a concept that
all of us kind of grasp so I too come
down on the side of uh first of all I I
find a lot of the the language in here
um bordering on offensive but um I um
also acknowledge the need for education
and the need for dialogue and the need
for um
uh more emphasis on the informed part of
the phrase informed
consent um so that having been said I uh
don't have any problem with people
working on something that's going to be
about education but if we're going to be
about consent forms or or specifics
about consent uh that's going to be a
hard no for me just so I don't have
anybody losing time over it and the more
I listen to the discussion here the more
I wonder if this bill might not be a
vehicle for True interim study uh to
talk about the consent issues that I
think all of us
recognize are very real and and needing
to be
addressed so I just throw that out there
as a thought representative McLean and
then representative pero yeah thank you
Mr chair and you know I I have enormous
respect for the doctors on on this
committee and uh the the fact that it is
very difficult to to put specific
language into law and I kind of support
that sentiment uh but the concern I have
was that the testimony being given
during the public hearing was so
compelling that you have people who had
just given birth who are having a form
that form should have been presented to
them weeks before so um so maybe the
solution is not to put it into statute
but the existing system it's not just
about what's in the form it's about the
mode of delivery and and that's very
important so um if we are going to
interim study it I think it should
absolutely be a real interim study I
agree uh this language is problematic
and probably you know representative
Weber the reason that the language is
maybe borderline offensive is because of
the experiences out of which it was born
and so I think we have to take that into
account and and be very sympathetic to
that so um I I would definitely um if we
are going to interim study it think that
that's something we have to give some
serious and honest consideration to and
those are my thoughts representative
Shapiro yes thank you Mr chairman
um I was affected by some of the
testimony um especially people who um
came and talked about not thinking about
this very very much um there being an
assumption that this is what happens to
all boys and then um those people maybe
had some ongoing medical um
complications and I was very sympathetic
to those stories um and I feel
absolutely that circumcision is an
elective surgery that people should be
educated people should have all the
information they need to make an
informed
decision that being being said um if
people continue to work on this bill I
think there's
a there's not only for me there's not
only a change from informed consent to
education that has to take place but I
think that
um I think that people who came um some
of the people who came to testify were
saying there's an assumption um a a bad
assumption
that little boys should be
circumcised and um and this is truly
elective
um people shouldn't assume that doctors
shouldn't um assume that they can just
stick something in front of the um the
the mom and get her to sign it and um
but what I think this bill the original
Bill does and what this um Amendment
does
equally is it creates the opposite
opposite bias um the bias in this bill
is that um this is a very dangerous
um procedure and you better watch out
you better look at these um tools that
are going to be used to do it um I would
say that just the term potential
benefits and inherent risks
um is you know is a biased way of
talking about this um there are
potential benefits and potential risks
as well um I understand that the some of
the um testimony was compelling to some
people but this was
a this was just a slice of people who
came to testify about this bill I mean
there was no testimony from anybody um
who was circumcised when they were a
young child like I was and have had a
perfectly normal life life and um a very
satisfactory life in regards to health
and various things so I think that
um this bill was brought with people
with a particular bias and we heard
testimony that we had a particular bias
and by all means if we're going to work
on something and pass something we don't
want it to have the opposite bias we
want it to be um informed scient I ific
neutral um we want to create a culture
where people can really learn and think
for themselves and make their own
informed decision um but this I find to
be dangerous to tell you the truth
representative Weber and then
representative Nagel I just wanted to
issue small apology for my remarks
earlier um and I wanted to make it clear
that I too
found a great deal of the testimony that
we heard very very compelling and I do
not in any way want to minimize that I
just don't think that this is the
appropriate solution but I have to say
um the the testimony was very compelling
um I will also say that my professional
development came through divorce work
and one is equ
informed by the fact that uh there are
some horrible divorces out there but and
those are the ones you hear about you
don't hear about the vast majority of
parents who suck it up talk to each
other uh make compromises for the
benefit of their children and go on to
be wonderful wonderful wonderful
co-parents um in a new setting uh so I
just wanted to make that apology and
make sure that I wasn't minimizing uh
the testimony that we heard thank you
representative Nel thank you Mr chairman
I I'd like to Second what you said
because it kind of began what I wanted
to say but I I feel compelled to say
stuff I wrote here earlier that I wasn't
going to say till later but
um you you nailed it I mean this is a
very biased presentation um when I
started you're not going to read three
pages are you yeah no no no no that
never mind I'm not reading three pages
I'm going to tell tell you is the
following I mean I spent an awful lot of
time on this issue I have no idea why
but you know to clarify what you just
said the satisfaction rate of males
who've had circumcision is 99% the
complication rate which was really
misrepresented is in a study in Israel
was
0.34% in the United States it's between
1 to 2% and most of the complications
are very shortterm and self-limited and
as one of my as Dr Conway who presented
here acknowledg the one gentleman had a
very serious complication and in the
study in Israel they had one but those
are extremely rare and and and I think
we got to be really careful about
biasing reality the other thing you
might want to do if you got nothing
better to do is I found a website
totally by accident of people that are
angry at their parents for not having
had them circumcised because all the
problems they've had from being
uncircumcised so there are definitely
two sides of this story but we're
finding out that 9 9% of us are in the
middle and we're just
fine representative L did you have a
comment representative kushman thank you
um Mr chairman I um well I I think that
this discussion is very important and
obviously um there's a lot more to hash
out here I'm going to withdraw my motion
and I'm going to move interim
study is is a second withdraw um sorry I
made the motion and I already offered to
withdraw it so I will withdraw it um and
yes I will withdraw my second and if I
may just um I just want to say that this
is clearly um a a complex issue there
was a lot of compelling testimony um
this is the only routinely done elective
surgery on infants and that's why it's
the gravity is what it is um there's
nothing else like this
so that's why it's it's special and
needs to be really considered as far as
that goes um I would like to see this
studied over the summer and I would be
happy to participate and I think this
broader informed consent conversation
definitely needs to um continue as well
thank you all right so representative
kushman you're moving inm study is there
a second second representative Weber
seconds any discussion on the motion for
inim study representative Murphy thank
you um
I I question about interim study on this
bill specifically because it it
perpetuates the concept of focus on
circumcision alone I would argue that
you know uh representative Shapiro
mentioned and people have mentioned
elective it is an elective procedure and
that it does not have to be done
emergently but it's not elective in the
sense that you need your total joint
replac and we can talk about it three
months ahead of time and then decide to
do it once you get Beyond about a week
or 10 days after the child is born The
increased risks are are there with
circumcision so not I wouldn't call it
elective I wouldn't call it emergent I
would call it in a sense somewhat
semi-urgent a decision needs to be made
so a point of clarification there only
um if I were to change the word here so
I'm looking at this the concept of
interim study and if I were to change
the word circumcision procedure to any
other procedure we do we would be doing
the same thing I I think there's two
issues going on here one is the concept
of the circumcision whether it's
appropriate whether people like it or
not I I take a offense not offense I
take I question the word Cosmetic in a
procedure that does have in many in
Cleveland Clinic studies and other
studies that does have some very
definite therapeutic benefits so it's
not only cosmetic um but I would also
argue that there are two parallel tracks
here one is the concern we have about
informed consent I agree with that maybe
we ought to work on that I'm not sure I
would ever get to the point of
legislating or putting in statute inform
consent language necessarily but that's
a separate issue from the procedure
itself and so I would
my opinion or my thought would be that
this becomes in my mind an
it for both the amendment and the bill
itself and if somebody wants to bring up
a separate and a future bill regarding
informed consent that could be done
later later date so I I'm still not sure
that interim study in my mind is the
best way to go if the presumption is
that we're still working on the concept
that circumcision is a procedure that
has to be focused on in this bill thanks
other representative
Weber
the other option that might be available
to us that is available to us if if
people are interested in it would be for
the chair to create an ad hoc
subcommittee of this committee to study
the broader issues of
consent which it's within your power to
do and I don't know whether that would
get us farther forward on this bill or
not and and the two are not mutually
exclusive we could
uh either itl or interim study this bill
and still have uh a committee to study a
broader issue if that's the will of the
chair and the committee representative
TZ representative
TZ uh thank
you so I'm I'm sitting here with a few
lenses on one is I train I'm a family
doc I did over 200 deliveries in
residency and I practiced in a place
where it was not sort of the culture of
the families that we served uh to have
circumcisions so while a few happened um
it you know it it was a parental
preference thing and nobody was
solicited you might get asked right but
you weren't uh lobbied so so some some
of the connotation that is hard for me
to relate to because I don't currently
practice right now here um and so that's
just a wondering I have as to like how
how is this how did this come to be
because we're talking about an elective
parental
Choice uh and then the issue of informed
consent um representative Murphy I
really appreciated your elaboration on
how it's a conversation and in current
times it is patient
Centric right and I just want to remind
us that there is a whole like a lot of
science and research to how to make
informed consent which may seem here
really easy in Black and White how to
make that better so there's a a lot that
goes into it's not just what gets shared
it's sort of the the context The
People's State what they remember might
vary and so it's not been easy over many
years to try to improve informed consent
and I'm not saying it's good or bad I'm
just saying like it's a it's a it's not
something can just legislate um or
create a form and that takes care of it
all so what I've heard is that there's a
concern that there's not education
happening I checked in with some OB
providers and and they'll say they
mention it you know it gets mentioned
and during the course of prenatal care
that if you're having a boy this will be
something you want to think about so if
the concern is that that all parents who
are aware of the gender of their
expected baby have never stopped to
think about what they would want to do
when the time comes then maybe we focus
on an education campaign or something
else that could easily be done out of a
public health department that is not
about legislating um the practice of
medicine um so I I think I think that's
it other discussion representative Lon
um thank you Mr chairman and I want to
thank the members of this committee for
talking about how important informed
consent is I think our larger disc
session of informed consent should
actually not address this bill but
should address House Bill 1280 which has
been presented in front of this
committee on February 7th um which has
to deal with informed consent um I think
that this is this is an area that I
think does warrant further study whether
or not we're making sure that there's
education there are some cultures where
it's assumed that you do some cultures
you assume that you don't and there's
some people where it's a religious right
so um I believe that interim study would
be a good path forward if we if that
does doesn't pass I'd suggest that we
hold off and move this one to March 6th
um so that anybody who wants to bring a
different Amendment could buy a March 6
Executive session if interim St he
doesn't pass but um I I think we're
probably right for a vote given that
we've discussed this pretty
thoroughly any final discussion on
this seeing none okay the motion is
interim study on hb1 1706 hyen
FN representative Lon
yes representative kushman yes
representative Bill King yes
Representative kofalt
no representative mlan
yes representative Seth King
yes representative Missour
yes representative Nagel
no representative n
yes representative Weber yes
representative McKay
no Representative fedus
no representative Canon
no representative Nutter upam
no representative
Shapiro
yes representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy
no representative
no Representative tez
no and
representative McDonald yes 11 to n
motion passes 11 to n
yes
okay representative kushman you'll do
the report on that yes I will thank
you is somebody going to write a
Minority
Report 11 to9 pass it pass 11 to
n okay all right so you're doing I'm
doing against I uh interim
study I I think the issue may be that
the people who voted in the minority may
have done so for a number of different
reasons um which are mutually exclusive
but perhaps somebody writing The
Minority Report might want to reference
the fact that there were various reasons
for voting that
way no thank you all right
representative Nagel you'll write The
Minority Report on that representative
Mel you'll write the minority
representative Shapiro does The Minority
Report have to reference what they are
supporting I'm sorry yeah the minority
report would have to give the
alternative like a to pass or IPL or and
and that may be a problem because I
think some of the people might have been
wanting a to pass and some might have
been wanting itl right can we have more
than one Minority Report I don't think
I've never heard of that I don't I've
never seen it so I I have no idea how to
square that Circle there is only one
Minority Report required we had another
bill where there was a desire for
two yeah
my suggestion is that we include that
there were a variety of different
options presented for this bill which
included an ad hoc committee um you know
a broader legislative committee or just
itl the bill in total or whatever I but
I I think we need to include all those
things sure I I agree the problem is
that we will also the clerk will insist
on whether the recommendation is itl or
ought to pass and I'm not sure or ought
to pass with Amendment all of which are
possibilities we don't know um we don't
know representative kof
fall uh thank you and thank you
representative Weber for pointing out
the fact that yes some of us did vote
against this not because we wanted to
itl but because we wanted to OTP having
said that I think that I am in the
minority of the minority in that view
therefore I I am comfortable if the
Minority Report presents an alter motion
of itl because I do believe perhaps
incorrectly um I would encourage others
to speak up if they if they share my
view let's put it that way um otherwise
I think it's safe for us to assume that
the the majority of the minority um
would prefer an itl motion so that if
OTP so that that if interim study fails
that would be the default U motion
that's made on the
floor so
now I lost
you you're writing an itl report
Minority Report so The Minority Report
is recommending itl and the I would
certainly The Minority Report is
recommending itl the majority report is
recommending in from the study right and
my you mean my request is that that
Minority Report should mention that not
everybody who voted in the minority
agrees with the itl rec
I'm writing itl the bill period not itl
interim study yeah and and what you're
going to do is exactly what uh
representative kofalt said uh people who
voted against interim
study voted against it for a number of
reasons some wanting to itl the bill
entirely some perhaps wanting a passage
with an
amendment and then you
say you you know we had to pick a we had
to pick a a recommendation so it seemed
like more of the people were on the itl
side rather and I'm this is not the
right kind of language but these are the
points you're going to get in there is
is that um um people were in
disagreement about what the actual
recommendation should be so the report
should honor that but we we we are
required to pick one or the other and I
think that representative kofalt and I
thank you for it um was was pretty
explicit in saying you know more of the
minority was for itl than not to pass
and we had to pick one can I say that if
I don't know
that because I don't know that we didn't
actually have a
vote I think that's king of Bridge to
Star to say that the fact is that
however you explain it yeah there will
have to be a
recommendation it will have to be either
ought to pass ought to pass with
Amendment which will have to have an
amendment number and we haven't voted on
any amendments or
itl so uh you don't have to be terribly
specific about it nor do you have to you
don't have to make assumptions I think
the only thing that everybody's agreed
on is that it's important to say
that the people who were not in favor of
interim study were also not NE
necessarily United in what they thought
ought to happen with the bill
representative
kofalt thank you Mr chairman and I think
if if if there were a large body of of
um people in the minority who agree with
my position I think we would have heard
from them by now so I I think it's very
safe to say that most of the minority
agree with the itl position
okay anyone else on uh 170
6 we clear where we going okay all right
now let's revisit uh hb1 1593 FN at this
point uh again it's an early Bill we do
need to get it resolved we have received
the latest Amendment from a
representative Leon I'll recognize her
for a motion uh thank you Mr chairman I
move that we adopt Amendment
2024-25
193 is there a
second representative McLean seconds
representative L do you want to speak to
your motion um thank you Mr chairman uh
this was delivered through uh from s
doing a heroic job getting it to us so
quickly it includes that se set language
that we had if you flip to the back page
the Department of Health and Human
Services shall include language in the
contracts designated in subp paragraph 4
to prioritize Services previously
included in individualized budgets and
it has an effective date upon passage um
so that's why we I had the date change
the this current fiscal year so that we
can get these Services back so I I think
this is what we had I don't know if we
need discussion or if we're ready for a
vote when the clerk is
ready any uh comments or discussion on
this
amendment seeing none Mr clerk whenever
you're ready motion is ought to pass on
Amendment 2024 hyphen
0709 H to HB 15593 FN
representative Lon yes representative
kushman yes representative Bill King yes
representative Koval yes representative
mlan
yes representative Seth King yes
representative Missour yes
representative Nagel yes representative
ner
yes is that a
yes
okay representative Weber yes
representative M
yes representative fedus
yes representative
Canon yes representative n upam
yes representative Shapiro
Hallelujah that the same thing as yes
that's a
yes representative
Merchant
yes representative Murphy yeses
representative
priest yes representative tez yes
representative McDonald yes 20 to
zero okay do I have another motion on
the main uh bill um yes Mr chairman I
move ought to pass as amended by
Amendment 709h on House Bill
1593 z a second representative mour
seconds any discussion on the main
motion seeing none when the clerk is
ready motion is ought to pass as amended
on hb1 1593 FN and just to be clear that
was L representative Lon and
representative Missour was seconded Lon
and Missour yes okay
gotcha representative Lan yes
representative kushman yes
representative Bill King yes
Representative kofalt
no representative mlan
yes representative Seth King
no representative Missour
yes represent
ner yes
nich oh you know what I totally space
okay you know I lost so much weight that
when I turn sideways I'm
invisible representative Nagel yes
point of order I made an error in my
when I verbalized my vote is it okay is
it possible to change it before the vote
is called yes you can change
it so you're changing your vote too to
no to no
okay representative
Nagel
yes representative ner yes
representative
Weber
yes representative McKay
yes representative fedus yes
representative Canon
yes representative nut upam yes
representative Shapiro
yes representative Merchant
yes representative Murphy yes
representative priest yes
yes representative Taos
yes representative McDonald
yes 17-
three he is that something that can is
there going to be a minority oh go ahead
representative Weber it has to go on the
regular calendar anyway because of the
appropriation okay that answers
that The Minority Report is another
discussion is there going to be a
Minority Report on that or for the three
that voted against
it no
okay okay it's been requested that we
move to
16004 uh
next so do I have a motion on
uh move your Amendment I'd like to make
a motion on an amendment on hb60 4
number 20
24-3 238 we have that Amendment he's
about to it out oh okay yeah I have it
here okay motion made and so a second to
the amendment second okay and please
distribute it then
I you want to read that that's my blur
and you can give Christina a thumbs up
that's did Amendment
get they're
coming
uh yes
Merchant thank
you all right and you gave her a th I
did
this amendment will be easier reading
than the last
one okay representative Nagel would you
like to speak to your motion um yes I I
mean I just want to follow up on the
testimony that I originally provided on
this bill um there's three parts to the
bill the first part defines electronic
medical records the second part is what
I call the um the provider um protection
portion which is number two the part
that we're striking with the amendment
is part three which is the patient
protection provision um when we talk
about the bill I'll discuss this all in
Greater detail as to why these are
important but um after talking with
stakeholders it became quite apparent
that number one is that what I wanted to
accomplish in three is to some extent
already in federal and local state
statute um my belief and that of my
patience and my observations is that it
doesn't work um what I wanted to do was
create something that worked it became
apparent that this won't accomplish that
and what we wanted to do was strike it
from the bill and have a discussion
probably longwinded over the summer to
come up with something that's more
workable
any other discussion on the
amendment see no other
discussion so the motion is ought to
pass then on 2024 hyen
0323 Amendment uh to House Bill 16004
FN representative Leon yes
representative kushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative copal yes representative
mlan
yes representative Seth King yes
representative Missour
yes representative Nagel yes
representative ner
yes representative Weber
yes representative McKay
yes representative fedus yes
representative Canon
yes representative nut upam yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy yes representative
priest yes representative tez yes and
representative McDonald yes 20 to
zero okay do I have a motion on 1604 FN
um I'd like to presentative Nagel like
to make a a motion out to pass on um HB
1604 as amended by the
amendment okay any uh is there a
second representative Le on seconds uh
do you want to speak to a motion sure
um I mean I gave a pretty in long-winded
discussion about this bill before I
don't know that I want to add much more
to that but um the first part is is is a
definition and I really feel strongly
that if you're going to put terms in
legis stat you need to Define what
you're talking about so that's why the
first part has a definition which did
not really appear in statute prior to
this um the second part is is intended
to be um to provide protection to
doctors and I'm just going to give you a
brief story but I met with a Democrat
Governor of which state I won't mention
a couple years ago and um he asked me a
question about the Affordable Care Act
and he asked me what did I think about
it and since we weren't meeting to talk
about that
I wasn't really prepared and I certainly
hadn't read the 2,000 page version of it
um and he looked at me and he said it's
all about cost and access and he said
this may improve access but it's going
to accelerate cost and that's going to
be a problem for private practices it's
going to be a problem for patients and
so on and so forth so inspired by that I
actually read the entire thing a couple
months later I happen to talk to the um
head of CMS for the Northeast region and
I asked asked him I said after reading
this I have some serious concerns about
the Affordable Care Act in terms about
patient access especially for complex
patients and miscellaneous other people
and his response to me was that the
trains left the station you're either on
it or you're not and my response to him
was my concern is your re rear wheels
off the track and I'll be more than
happy to catch up and when the train
falls off the tracks totally I'll try to
help you get back on there were two
issues that were important in that disc
discussion one was prior authorization
and the other one was the electronic
medical record I provided a quote for
you with the original testimony about my
concerns about how people that are in it
feel about the disaster that the
electronic record has been and how it's
harmed uh communication between doctors
and patients cost of Private Practice
which I think should be the Bedrock of
Health Care um and so I won't go into
that any further but my attempt here is
to try to put the the train back on the
tracks in a direction I think we don't
really want it to go um the other thing
that inspired me in doing this is I
believe in whole person integrated care
and right now we have a whole bunch of
providers that are excluded from that
model such as chiropractors
acupuncturist massage therapists and
other people have a lot to contribute
who are not being included now and it's
my sincere hope that they will be in the
near future um this bill would allow
them to do what they're doing without
being forced to use an electronic record
to submit their bills and things like
that because to be hon honest that would
threaten their financial existence and I
don't think that's good for patients or
providers and I think on that note I'll
end representative
Weber thank you Mr chair and first of
all I'm incredibly sympathetic to the
points that you're making um
because I think they're right okay so
that's item number one item number two
is I have a concern with paragraph two
of the bill
uh because I talked to a colleague on um
Commerce and their concern that it is um
inir conflict with federal law and I
don't know enough about this area to be
able to deal with whether that's okay or
whether that's not okay and I was
wondering if it would be possible for us
to put this off and have our researcher
do a little more research on that issue
uh because on the one hand uh I would I
would like to do anything in my power to
make this particular situation better
but I don't think getting us into a
conflict of laws state if that's what's
going to happen would actually get us
farther forward and we may be removing
one more wheel from the track which I
would rather not
do representative Nagel with do you have
a response sure um so one of the points
that I made when I presented this bill
originally was that
um I had a very I'm I'm sorry this is a
little bit circular but um I work with
University of Rochester school of
healthc care policy economics and they
voiced a concern that it's not that that
is happening it's really happening is
that we're witnessing healthc care being
taken over by increasing and increasing
size of entities that they use the
electronic record for data collection
and for um billing purposes to the EXP
uh uh to the um harm of patients
basically I mean we we've lost our focus
on what we're doing this is true at the
federal and state levels my original
reason to bring this bill actually
forward was to make a very very very
public statement that we got to stop
this and it and it's not just a local
level it's a federal level and it what's
f to me was the prior authorization bill
that I initially brought was brought for
the same reason in the process of us
doing that we put a lot of pressure on
the federal government to realize what
they're doing wrong is wrong with that
as well and in the end they ended up
passing legislation or recently CMS just
passed a total change in the way they're
doing prior authorization that totally
mirrored the bill that we created and so
now we have two parallel bills that both
will solve a problem and it's my intent
that this is a very public statement
that what you're doing is wrong that you
can't require people to be your data
collectors and you're billing people
that you you can't ruin people's
practices and that you need to stop
doing this and that I think that my hope
is that what we're doing here will not
conflict but align with what should
become federal
policy what about the suggestion now you
made the motion to um about to pass is
amended representative Weber has
suggested further
research uh that was my specific uh
question I mean my gut sense is I really
want to go ahead um I and this is going
to be really rude and and um lady gadiva
is of me but um I think that making this
statement's incredibly important and I I
would I understand your point because
it's been raised twice to Me Now by two
different insurers who both agreed that
this bill is a good idea but both said
what you said representative Shapiro and
then representative
Merchant yes I'm I know there was
some questioning of whether this should
have gone to our committee to Commerce
in the first place and I'm so I'm
wondering if we pass this bill and can
we make a recommendation that it go to
Commerce or is that it's I would make
it's going to be too late for an early
bill at that
point the clerk the clerk's standing
there and shaking his
head there's your answer but I would
love it representative
Merchant thank you Mr chairman um I do
have concerns about the federal Rissa
the Employee Retirement insurance safety
act which was passed in
1974 and that will take precedent over
any state law so what I'm not sure about
back to represent Weber are we running
into a a situation where the federal law
trumps the state law in this Arena and I
really don't know I think we need to
find out I also would say if you wanted
to change it represent Nel let put down
that any public health carrier governed
by State law versus Federal law maybe at
least a way to avoid the conflict
between the federal and the state I I'm
really sorry that was a great point and
one of the things that you and I have
learned in our six years together on all
the stuff we've done is that we do here
has a very small effect on the Health
Care system as a whole what I write here
can only affect State not federal
insurers so what we would write here
would have no effect on Medicare
Medicaid whatever um so I I think that's
a wonderful idea so would you be open to
amending the amendment to be sure we're
only talking about state law and not run
a foul of federal law that's fair I'm
fine with that so are you then saying
you're going to withdraw your
motion
we quickly go up to uh the fourth floor
with the draft and uh get it to us to
get it to the fourth floor fourth floor
to pass out to our colleagues to review
the
amendment all right so you had you had
second I'll withdraw my second and um
just as a little bit more of that
procedural we um have hearings in the
afternoon and we actually have noticed
to continue our executive sessions
tomorrow um at 10:40 after two hearings
and I know um OS is pretty stressed so
if I think we'll be able to have it in
time for that they have quite a few
amendments given the deadline so I think
if we aim to try and have that for
tomorrow when we restart executive
sessions at 1040 I think that'll be a
great way to get this done and I would
just representative Weber I I would just
add that I I very much appreciate that
um Amendment and that would make me much
happier it's probably true anyway but I
would be much happier in in voting for
it um so thank you all very much
okay so um and I know there's some
scheduling issues
um some individual scheduling issues
from what I understand U and we've
already noticed that tomorrow we will
continue executive session we actually
may be able to see what happens after
our hearings today I don't know if
there's a problem with anybody being
able to attend that noticed executive
session at 10:40 which is uh well ahead
of the caucuses and
session Mr chairman representative
Merchant it's more of a
timeline can we exact on something
tomorrow and still get a community
report in time to get it into the
calendar we've done all the early ones
we've done all the early ones yes this
but this is a fiscal note would it have
an early one it's not early yeah all
fiscal note bills are not necessarily
early okay thank you the two early bills
that we had to get done we did get done
and I should have mentioned this at the
beginning uh there was a little
confusion about HB 1585 that has been
continued to March 6
there had been previously um announced
that it would be we would we would
continue to March 6 and then we
mistakenly had noticed it for today so
representative Weber I think there's
some some question here about timing and
I'd love to hear about it but uh we do
have a session noticed tomorrow and I
think we have what three bills left is
that correct well if we put the 1604 off
we'll have four tomorrow um oh okay well
in any case we
but all of the bills that we have left
to take up are are are not on deadline
so none of them are on deadline so they
don't have to be finished and if I could
then um if not on a deadline could we do
hold off until next week when we exec on
those
bills it's it's up to the chair and to
is there is there a specific reason you
want to put that off or to take off some
of the pressure on OS and the people
upstairs in it's only a couple of words
for this one so I think tomorrow is okay
rather than next week it's always good
to move it along as quickly as we can
getting them off our plate is a really
good thing if we can get it done if they
can't get it done then they can't get it
done and we can't vote on it
so so B based on this conversation we
would be continuing hb1 1683 FN hb1 1660
FN HB 1568 FN and
hb04
FN any
questions okay and uh again we have
hearings this
afternoon uh and we will recess until
then
works then that gives us 11 more minutes
to have lunchtime before hearings so
we're Mr chairman so we're putting off
these other bills as
well okay
okay
that
feel that feel okay you to with that I
be honest I mean I knew it was a problem
befor and my intent was never to
infect
yeah I mean no that was a
brilliant I mean I think in the reality
is just wouldn't I I think I think that
that's right if it
pass the effect but I think it's much
better to make it very specific that we
understand what we're doing as opposed
to oh we didn't know what we were do we
we should I mean I should have been more
proactive about that but you know that
said I mean it's kind of inspired me to
have meetings with
andever um you know
about you know this issue because it's
you know I was shocked that CMS
literally passed that statement two days
before our hearing on the other and that
dramatic prior authorization bill and I
was like all right fine you guys are
looking at this stuff this is great so
you know I think we can pair our efforts
betterly it gives me a reason to meet
with
yeah and you know I know from being a
small provider that this affects a lot
of people oh my
God in the last 10 years I was in
Project practice and I couldn't afford a
medical not only couldn't I afford
it it would have well if you're to be
honest it's doing that to a lot of
people now and it's the reason why you
know they look record as the leading
cuse of
Bur that's I mean we're talking like 60
60% of the
VAR my thought is here it says
no Private health
care so on line
eight all we're doing is saying no
public or private healthare carrier
governed by state law
sh
you're a
master
[Music]
reconcil okay um where are
you
[Music]
I
good afternoon everyone and welcome back
to the health and human services and
elderly Affairs Committee of the New
Hampshire House of
Representatives first bill for a hearing
this afternoon was HB
1028 and I recognize the prime sponsor
already in place he must have done this
before and representative JD Bernardi
welcome representative
Bernardi thank you chairman McDonald and
committee uh JD bernardy Rockingham 36
Hampton Falls Kensington Southampton
Newton and plastow Southeast New
Hampshire um sponsor of uh HB
1028 a bill relative to the definition
of mental illness for the purposes of
New Hampshire Mental Health Services
system uh I provided a copy of EV of the
bill in larger print for everyone
hopefully it's on in front of you and I
invite you to look at the definition uh
RSA 135
SE uh to Roman X or 10 um and the the
interesting thing there is focus on the
last sentence and I think you can
understand that treatment of
impairment for emotional
processes can be and should be different
if the issue is epilepsy drug addiction
or alcohol addiction or other uh
intoxication yet intellectual disability
has been lumped in with that category
that's an inappropriate
segregation um and as noted in the in uh
C colon 3
um it is also there's segregation there
for co- concurrence with development uh
disability so I I know you received
comments from the New Hampshire
Community Behavioral Health Association
that said services are available to
these folks services are provided for
these folks nothing uh prohibits their
treatment but I filed this bill on on
the behalf of folks who are not being
adequately treated and and that that's
what needs to be addressed um I'm not
going to go into a big discussion of
those those issues that you have several
pink cards of people who want to talk
about the exact rationale uh for that
and among them is an Sanic who was the
driver of of this uh Bill's uh
presentation so uh I'd be happy to
answer any questions but I would really
like you to hear their
stories okay any questions for
representative
Bernardi I'm seeing none thank
you can I go your name again was Ann an
Sonic s a n o
k okay you can proceed uh we do ask all
testimony be kept to three minutes
please to what how many minutes uh three
three oops okay um I'll try talk
fast all right uh thank you uh
representative bernardy and thank you
chairman and committee members as
representative my name is an Sonic I'm a
parent of a 28-year-old young male who
is intellectually disabled and autistic
I've been involved in the field of
Developmental Disabilities as you'd
understand for many many years um I'm
presently um associated with one sky and
on the board of directors for farmsteads
of New England a residential Day program
for people with intellectual
disabilities located in eping and in
Hillsboro I live in exor I'm an attorney
and I teach Business Law at Southern New
Hampshire
University as representative Bernardi uh
pointed out to you uh really what we're
targeting here are the definition
sections under the mental health statute
of 135 C colon 2 it defines mental
illness and there's a clause in there
shockingly includes a clause which
excludes those with development
intellectual disabilities from Mental
Health Services it says it does not
include P impairment primarily caused by
epilepsy intellectual
disability uh you know related drug or
alcohol uh problems so really what we're
looking for is to remove that Clause
from the
statute really we're trying to end
discrimination against persons with
intellectual disabilities and improve
the mental health services in in New
Hampshire um it's been an evolution
obviously mental health has changed
dramatically over the past decades
indeed centuries there's always new
insights into mental illness
advancements in Science Education
medicine and law uh it's certainly a
process of trial and error and one of
the main errors that Still Remains a
huge problem it's been a detriment and
Major Impact on individuals indiv uh
intellectual disabilities
their families and certainly the pockets
of the taxpayer is that persons with
intellectual disability are often the
ones stuck in ER for weeks months at a
time we all you've all heard about the
problem with ER boarding going on in the
hospitals in New Hampshire uh I can
attest to that uh having my son having
been uh in there uh for 28 days in
exiter at one time uh the ER is not
equipped as you've heard probably in
different uh meetings to deal with
problems of psychiatric boarding uh a
state hospital the state hospitals refus
to admit them uh often not always uh
despite having all the resources to
handle uh and treat a said persons with
intellectual disabilities and so they're
they they sit in there and their
warehouse there often for my son was for
20 28 days uh while he was there not one
doctor not one social work from the
community health Center or state
employee really had a solution he was
clearly in the throws of a psychotic
break and that's why we brought him
there that's why these parents bring
them there they're not like hey let's go
to the emergency room today um uh there
there's a major problem going on and
it's very different often than what has
been going on at home um uh with the
person uh that's why every in person
with intellectual disability ends up in
the ER they're told to go there by by
the Community Mental Health Centers and
by the area agencies by their social
workers by the doctors everyone goes go
to the and then they find that nothing
really happens um New Hampshire State
Hospital refused to admit my son at that
time on grounds he was autistic and that
his symptoms and behaviors were only
related to that or primarily related to
that and that brings me back to that
clause in the statute which says
primarily impaired due to they latch on
to that becomes the pass uh free pass uh
that they don't have to address it yeah
if you could startop please wrapping up
okay um basically uh this can't be
resolved by it's the it's not my
department Mantra and that's what that
provision in the statute does everyone
cannot stay in their own lane on this
issue uh and with the language that's in
there there needs to be a conduit
between the state agencies and removal
of this phrase which expressly excludes
individuals with disability mental
disabil intellectual disabilities from
our mental health care and this would be
a step in the right direction the
subject Clause only exacerbates the
problem removing it will motivate the
mental health system in this state as
well as the other ancillary
organizations to work together to
address this Gap in the system and end
the discriminatory allocation of mental
health services so I urge you to support
this bill on behalf of of people with um
intellectual disabilities who really
been shut out of really important care
and treatment thank you thank you you
taking questions or oh uh representative
mlan thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question do you understand
the history of why this incl this
exclusion is there in the first place I
I think I do I think it's sort of
twofold one is to make sure that people
with intellectual disabilities don't get
mislabeled as mentally ill uh but I I
think the other primary uh uh reason is
is really it's not my department um that
there's a really sort of um you know
you're you're intellectually disabled
these people are mentally ill you know
these people are this and it's not that
clear there should be there's not that
defined distinction in reality and to
exclude them it it it it does have
doctors a lot of doctors and
psychiatrists are not really familiar
with people with intellectual
disabilities with down syndromes with
autism they don't get it that's not what
they do just like the heart surgeon
doesn't know about um you know setting a
bone and uh it becomes an because
there's that presumption it's like a
legal presumption that's been put in an
unjustified legal presumption has been
put in the statute that's a trigger and
a signal to uh these pych units and
hospitals to go oh no we don't have to
do that because it's primarily caused by
your autism or your Down syndrome your
behavior whatever you're doing uh if
you're aggressive if you're uh you know
having Illusions and um and and and
that's wrong it doesn't work I think it
might have been well intended for sure
uh but it's become that that's the
reason why people are sitting in the
emergency rooms and then ultimately I
would tie it to the fact that many of
these people with intellectual
disabilities after they've been in the
emergency room no place to go in New
Hampshire you know where they're sent
Texas uh Massachusetts um uh uh
Pennsylvania you know we're we're
spending up to a half a million dollars
sometimes on these people if you just
took the time to stabilize them you
might have avoided that major life event
and crisis follow up so just a quick
followup then on that in the case of
your son who was kept at the ER for 28
days what was the ultimate resolution
there he never got admitted to um they
were trying to get him to New Hampshire
hospital they actually took him up in an
ambulance uh well he was there like a
week took him up he was in there less
than 10 minutes he didn't get off the
stretcher they sent him back and just
phoned and said not not taking him he's
autistic so he stayed in the emergency
room again 28 days um and then finally
um the Bureau of Developmental Services
after you know scrambling around found a
placement in Massachusetts the judge
renberg Center and he was taken down
there by ambulance uh and he was you
know he was really stable able you know
within a a week of being there um he
ended up staying there for a longer
period but um yeah I mean it we need to
deal with the stuff in the house and we
have to we need more Cooks in the
kitchen on this not less and these these
people need to work and it's not going
to disrupt the system by taking out a
phrase uh it's going to force the
parties to talk together new policies
new Arrangements new conversations um
instead of going not my department next
window uh questions representative uh
Nagel and then representative Merchant
uh thank you Mr chairman thanks for
taking my question first of all I would
like to thank you and the sponsor for
bringing this bill in this is very
important to me personally um and I
really appreciate that you did it and I
think it's simultaneously sad that you
did it comorbidities are really common
and we really can't differentiate what I
what I I what I'm wondering about is
number one how pervasive do you think
this problem actually is and is it
is there any relation to severity and
the only reason I asked that question is
I have an autistic son um he's quote
high functioning whatever that means
we've never had troubles with the mental
health system and I I'm just curious if
if this issue is as pervasive as you're
saying and it's pervasive for a small
population uh and if they go to the
emergency I would say it's extremely
pervasive so yeah it's not going to
impact a huge amount of people but I
can't even tell you that H that we go
through when you're in that situation
and New Hampshire's under a court order
by The District Court uh to n boarding
in 2025 actually it's supposed to be
2024 but I guess there's an extension
till next
year are these are these folks factored
into that equation is the mental health
going oh yeah okay we've got we're going
to board more people now in our own
psych units take them out of the ER but
not you and not you and not you so
what's the hospital going to do um you
know I I mean they PE the mental health
system needs to take some ownership of
this it has to be a shared uh allocation
of resources and shared delivery of of
services and um it it is pervasive for
the folks who do have intellectual
disability and do go to the ER um and
they're they're they're not being taken
occasionally they are occasionally they
are and sometimes they do receive
services at the community health centers
but not always my son is denied services
at Northern Community Human Services up
in the conquer Conway area because he
can't participate in talk therapy he
does need Med he needs half these people
if not more are on antis psychotic drugs
and depr anti-depressants they're taking
the same medication that that normal
mental ailed people are are taking or
you know there people among us are on
that you know you function live your
life um they won't see him because he
can't participate in talk therapy well
now they have to go find some contractor
doctor tell a uh you know which works
fine for him but again another example
of well we don't do it that way well
well you need to accommodate this
particular population and do it
differently that's the point
representative Merchant then
representative
Shapiro thank you Mr
chairperson thank you for taking my
question I concur this is a very
important issue that we need to solve
and do it correctly
and terminology is so important both in
statute as well as rules I'm looking
over you brought the issue of autism and
based upon what I've been able to find
on Google Dr Google Mr
Google autism is not considered a mental
illness or intellectual disability it
does cause issues with learning per se
but it's not listed as a quote mental
health issue so I want to be sure that
we don't somehow EX exclude what I think
you're trying to get to is children with
autism that need to be taken care of
because if we don't use the right words
we may inadvertently have AED conse
autism isn't in there I mean it's a good
point mean know it's it's a question of
semantics a lot of times typically
though I would say uh the UN you know
they use the word intellectual
disability because you you can be on the
autism spectrum and not have an
intellectual disability so technically
under this framing of the language you
wouldn't be excluded but believe me if
that word autism
slips out of your mouth and they call up
New Hampshire State Hospital they're
going to hang their hat on that because
it's equated with intellectual
disabilities and many people with um
most people uh when you're when you're
associated with an area agency they're
the ones who deliver services to those
with a developmental disability the
people often that they take who are
Autistic or down syndrome they do have
an intellectual disability it's just you
different words are often
interchangeable but not always
followup thank you for that and I do
concur I think a lot of times words are
semantics but they're important
semantics and I just want to be sure
that whatever we're writing in the bill
that we get the right words that we need
to take care of the issue we're trying
to solve well I think if you take out
the word intellectual disability they
they shouldn't be saying I'm denying you
because of autism they do do say that
but really what they're they're meaning
is we see you as in then that person may
be intellectually disabled often they
are call my son autistic but he's
definitely intellectually disabled
that's a lot of syllables so it's just
easier to say they're autistic people
kind of get that if you I say he's
severely autistic that's even a better
description but I think if you remove
the phrase intellectual disability
there'd be no basis to carp lanch deny
somebody certainly doctors can make
assessments and in their own
professional judgment evaluate but you
can't do it over the phone and you can't
do it in a 10-minute thing you need to
talk to the parents you need to talk to
the school you need to talk to the
primary you need to look at the medical
records that's not happening and that's
proper standard of care they just go on
the word autism or intellectual
disability case closed representative
Shapero and then representative
Kofa thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking this question I I hear your
frustration with
um receiving or not receiving U mental
health um
Services whether it's New Hampshire
hospital or services in the emergency
room or just outpatient services from a
Community Mental Health Center I I hear
your frustration and I understand it and
I think that there's our mental health
infrastructure is really lacking in this
state for people with developmental
disabilities and for people without
developmental disabilities so I
understand completely why you would want
to put in
um in the second part of this bill an
individual shall not be determined
ineligible for services under this
chapter based on a co-occurrence of
mental illness I that makes total sense
to me I'm less clear why you're
interested in making the other change
which crosses
out um parenthesis B intellectual
disability because just like you said in
the beginning you don't want people to
be assumed it says
it does not include impairment primarily
caus caused by these conditions so like
you said in the beginning you don't want
the assumption that someone is mentally
ill if they're not mentally ill but
they're developmentally disabled or they
have epilepsy or so it's a little bit
less clear to me why I'm not sure if
you're the one asking for the change but
it's a little bit less clear to me why
you want that change uh because I think
that it's a it's a it's a say um first
of all I don't think that group needs to
be in there number one why are they in
there uh why is in yes it's really um
you're removing that and then you're re
reiterating the reminder that
co-occurring can occur basically uh that
phrase intellectual disability just
needs to be taken out of the bucket
because it's a trigger and it's a signal
to mental health professionals that oh
this isn't um they're they're not going
to be able to see what's happening um
and it allows them to kind of gravitate
towards that as the causation rather
than sort of keeping an open mind and
really examining everything
um I think that does that answer your
question say it again I hear it no I
think that I I think that does answer
the question I'm not it's not it doesn't
respond to the logic but it responds to
the the message you want to give to
people they shouldn't exclude these
people because they have somebody from
the Community Mental Health Center will
tell you oh we treat people with
co-occurring let's and they do have
people with intellectual disabilities go
in there uh not always sometimes they
will say not uh but you know really my f
main focus is is sort of the ER boarding
and the lack of short-term or long-term
um psych uh impatient care but I think
removing intellectual disability just
changes the conversation like you have
to deal with this this is a co-occurring
we're going to start there we're not
going to go oh is the prime what is
primary impairment is it 90% is it 60%
is it 40% are we going to get into that
it's it's impossible in many instances
to parse that out um doctors you know
certainly still have that discretion in
their professional judgment to make an
analysis and an evaluation of the person
but basically my point is that phrase is
really shutting the door in many
instances where many instances I've
talked to many parents really over the
last six years I get five or six calls
every year from a parent I heard you
went through this what do I do I'm I'm
in Elliott my son's been in there 14
days blah blah blah um and they're they
just called and said uh autism that they
got a phone call from the state hospital
or from the a psych unit that they
didn't even see the person they just
have the ER report and they call and say
oh no no we're not taking them so that's
why I want that out follow up follow up
so it's your experience or experience
you've heard about that specifically New
Hampshire hospital excludes people even
if they have a co-occurring disorder
sometimes they do and sometimes they
don't but they have because they have
the yeah I mean I realize there's a bed
issue too and and that that could be a
justifiable but I do think there's
cherry-picking going on and I think that
phrase helps it's just discriminatory to
me on its face thank you representative
thank you for the question
representative kofalt and then
representative McKay thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question so uh following up on
representative Merchant's question um if
we were not to remove anything but to
just add something like comma including
autism uh or in would or or if we were
to specifically include autism would
that be would would you have any reason
to object to that yes I would I think
that would complicate it not simplify it
I think if we remove it out the convers
that the doctors you know you're just
going to deal with the person based on
the the symptomology that's being
presented in the entire medical history
you're not why is that in there it's an
unjust presumption of ineligibility and
it should not be a legal presumption um
I think taking that out every you know
the like I said doctors still have
discretion uh you know who's doing the
admissions and whatnot to evaluate the
appropriateness of that admission but to
just go over over the phone they're
autistic we're not taking them or I
don't understand this and believe me
they do not understand it there's a
diagnostic manual that many people even
at the community health centers are
unaware of you've heard the diagnostic
manual for you know psychiatric symptoms
and um this one is dm2 ID I have a a a
friend who is a therapist at seos mental
health she said never heard of it we
didn't have it there wasn't trained in
it social work school never had a
training here I you know if anything by
doing this you're going to make the
Mental Health Community more educated
and aware of Developmental Disabilities
and they can use that expertise to work
with the Bureau of Developmental
services with the area of agencies say
let hey let's come together and and and
come up a solution maybe they can have
some dedicated beds or people trained in
developmental disabilities they can go
there instead of being boarded at the uh
ER they're going to have to go there in
a year and they can't deny them and if
they do deny them there's going to be a
lawsuit they need to be trained on this
and educated like I said mental health
is an evolving process there's all new
information Discovery we want like I
said we want more people on this not
less and that's why I think that phrase
needs to be removed followup
representative kofalt um yeah so I want
to clarify my question I'm I'm
suggesting that in the language that is
added that said an individual shall not
be
denied that we would specifically add
autism to that so that it is very very
clear that intellectual or developmental
disability shall include autism you're
saying you would object to that oh no no
thank you you can you know just more
more people might want to add other
definitions but um yeah that that would
be fine I would have I don't think
anyone representative McKay and then
representative
Weber thank you Mr
chairman u i probably should ask should
have asked the uh sponsor of this bill
um
uh I
feel that these statements do not
reflect the system that's in that's in
effect in New Hampshire New Hampshire
has a very
comprehensive program uh in mental
health and Community Mental Health
Services the DD population is totally
separate from that it's not separate sir
it's not separate they're they're
connected many many times most people
who many people with intellectual
disability a autism and down syndrome
are on uh anti-depressants anxiety
medications uh they're on uh anticho
they're on mood disorder drugs it's not
separate it's no different than any of
the regular popul population the
currence of mental illness in people
with intellectual disabilities and your
regular population it's it's the same
percentage so it's not separate and um
they need to be joined together and
there needs to be communication but I'm
sorry I interrupted
you yes you did uh the uh my my
background is mental health I used to be
in charge of Community Mental Health
Services I was in private practice this
as a psychotherapist for 35 years I have
five college
degrees uh so that some of the things
you're saying are based on the pain that
you have experienced dealing with the
system uh because they're not accurate
of what you're saying and I can see
people sitting in the audience who are
agreeing with you I hope there's
somebody from the Department uh for for
example the department produces every 10
years State Mental Health Plan I don't
know if you're familiar with that I
wrote the one before this and not one
part of that was ever implemented
because we hit the
recession uh the cost of Metal Health
Services is
extensive uh and but
the what what this does the is
not uh describing the mental health
system that's in effect in New Hampshire
well what it does show is some of the
complaints that people have had and I
have been very strong about what we call
the borders the number of people who are
like today if you go up to conget
hospital
you go down a certain Ward there are
people in there that New Hampshire
hospital is not ready yet they don't
have the vacancy to have those people in
there the legislature has passed new
legislation they're building new
facilities and I could hope that the
families of those with mental illness
would would be the
supporters of developing a more
comprehensive system rather
than than attacking them uh it's a
extremely complex issue uh but that I
think New Hampshire over the last 20
years has done a remarkable job of
providing care to the most severely
mentally ill I I I agree with you in a
lot of respects but there's a gap and
they haven't been um providing
significant care to this population and
um we do by passing this bill I feel
like we're contributing in a positive
way to improving a comprehensive um
mental health system I mean certainly
anyone in the leadership position and
who's been involved in mental health for
a long time you know you see the great
work that you've done and you want to
tout that but you're hearing from people
in the trenches from the people who were
there dayt day and you're like you know
what this isn't working for for this
group and we've been saying that for a
while and nothing's changed and
sometimes the only way to change things
is through a law and by this law and by
removing that phrase I feel that it can
improve it even more and and and and
make those new uh beds that are being
developed dedicate some of those beds to
this population your the agency that you
know you worked with for so long they're
the ones equipped to deal with people in
psychiatric crisis not the ER it doesn't
matter whether the person has autism
Down syndrome an intellectual disability
or
anything that mental
health is is is equipped to deal with it
and whether that person goes in for
short term for a issue while the Breer
of Developmental PL finds a a s you know
maybe they can't return home and they
need to go into residential placement ER
is not the place to stabilize them the
Mental Health Organization is and so
that's why we want to improve the
overall uh delivery of services and make
it um a fair to everyone follow up
follow up I I know I'm not going to get
any place with my point of view I'm
hoping that somebody from the Department
uh you have to ask a question you can't
State okay when the
department actually I don't believe any
fromone from the Department is here at
least not sign up yet but um let me just
say would would you believe that perhaps
the legislature might form a study
committee to look into the concern that
you have I mean I I don't think that
complicated I think you can avoid that
whole delay and just remove the phrase
and then let the parties work it out
together um you know committees study
committees are good but I I think that
it's you know I I think it's a really
common sense and clear um uh solution to
this and if I thought otherwise I'd say
so but I I don't thank you very much
thank you representative Weber and then
representative
Merchant I I think my question was
really a followup to the questions of
both representatives of merchant and
kofalt and was based
on the question
of uh autism not being exactly the same
thing as an intellectual disability it's
not that there may be overlap but there
may not and and I think your answer to
representative
kofalt um may have clarified the issue
for all of us and are you still saying
that it's okay to uh that perhaps use
autism as a specific add in that second
that that last part of the statute you
know well yeah I wouldn't be opposed to
that but then I'd be worried that well
people with Down Syndrome they're like
well he doesn't my my kid doesn't I
don't think he has autism he has Down
syndrome now what about him I don't know
you know I just feel like intellectual
disability so is is comprehensive enough
I may have a followup but but my problem
is that intellectual disability is not
necessarily
coextensive with autism you could have
somebody with
autism
who
is very high functioning who then has
mental health issues coexisting with
their
autism and I'm I'm speaking from
knowledge of a member I don't want what
I'm trying to work at is the language
that will include all the people we want
to include and not exclude some maybe in
the tag could be shall not exclude uh
people with intellectual disabilities
people with Autism people with Down
Syndrome um who have co-occurring you
know um diagnosis or or symptoms it's
not really even diagnosis because they
haven't gotten it yet um you know I
think removing the term intellectual
disability um autism technically like I
said I think a lot of medical providers
equate that term with autism but you're
right certainly there's people who uh
don't have an intellectual disability
and if they say the word autism but if
that word phrase is removed I think that
removes that technically that
presumption for anything you know
there's no technically no presumption
that they autism isn't in there it's
grouped under intellectual disabilities
so once you remove intellectual
disabilities um you know to me that
falls under that umbrella and that they
would have no they would have no basis
even now of denying them Services if
there was no evidence of an intellectual
disability uh I think that they they may
at some time but um if if they you
know representative
Merchant my question was answered okay
other
questions saying not thank you okay
thank
you also signed up to speak is Karen
Rosenberg from the disability rights
Center of New
Hampshire and you've got three
minutes good afternoon I'm Karen
Rosenberg I'm the policy director at the
disability rights Center the state's
protection and advocacy system I've held
the role as policy director for just a
little over two years and for the 15
years prior to that I represented
clients in kinds of matters involving
their disability and I can tell you that
it's pretty common in our office to hear
from people with who experience a
developmental disability or intellectual
disability to be denied services from
the Community Mental Health Center and
um and it's problematic it feels kind of
like a nimy situation not in my backyard
because you've got someone who
experiences both an intellectual
disability and a mental health
impairment and then they you know go to
the area agency the area agency says
well you got you got to go to the mental
health agency because you're really you
know you're in the throws of a mental
health crisis and they go to the mental
health agency who says uh not so much
because you've got a developmental
disability or an intellectual disability
and so you're really not ours and then
the person's nobody's and when I've
represented clients who experience
co-occurring developmental disabilities
and mental health impairments who are
fortunate enough to have Private health
insurance they are able to get their
needs met they get both you know they
get all the needs met they get their
development needs met they get through
the medical system they get their mental
health needs met through their private
practitioners and it seems really
fundamentally unfair that our law on the
books would preclude people from being
able who experience developmental
disabilities or intellectual
disabilities from getting those Services
I understand there are some um Community
Mental Health Centers that are doing a
really good job of collaborating and are
seeing people who experience both but
the fact is our current law is something
that another mental health agency can
rely on to deny services to someone who
really needs it so for all those reasons
our um the disability rights Center
strongly supports passage of this bill
and I'm happy to take any
questions thank you any questions
representative
Weber I'm just still trying to explore
this um concept of Are We being broad
enough are we being inclusive enough and
um as I'm looking up dsm5
I'm realizing that I may not have had
the proper definition of intellectual
disability but the subject of De
developmental
disabilities has also been raised in
this context and I'm wondering what you
think about the inclusion of those with
developmental disabilities as well as
intellectual disabilities so I think so
are you talking about the second part of
the bill right so it currently or is
that addressed elsewhere in statute if
you know no I think it would need to be
in this bill that you would need to make
it clear and and one other thing you
might consider is getting rid of the
double negative I think there was some
confusion about what the double negative
meant um was making my head hurt you
might want to consider a language like
an individual shall not be denied
Services Under this chapter on the basis
of co-occurrence of mental illness and
an intellectual or developmental
disability now I think developmental
disability encompasses autism there are
people behind me who know more about
this than me another population that is
not included in this that you might
consider are people who have exper who
have brain injuries because those are
also folks who can who may have
co-occurring mental illness along with
having experienced a brain injury who
could also benefit for mental health
services so it this may also present an
opportunity to ensure that those those
folks aren't similarly denied
Services thank you that's very help
other
questions representative Coachman thank
you Mr chairman and thank you for being
here and taking my question um we're
starting to build a bigger list of um
groups of people who we don't want to
exclude and I as I'm listening um I'm a
nurse and I've had many patients I I
deal with the geriatric population
primarily patients with dementia um who
many are on psychiatric medications um
and so I just have concerns about these
um adding all of these categories that
we going to inadvertently miss somebody
um what are your thoughts on that um
that that is really interesting I mean
one thing you could do you could
consider is a um sort of a catch all
including but not limited to situation
um and probably a clinician would be a
better person to craft the language for
you but it might be
you know you could have something like
you know a cur a
co-occurring um let's see basis of a
co-occurrence of mental illness and an
intellectual developmental um or other
condition you know
impacting I don't know some kind of
brain functioning but like I said I I
would defer to a clinician to really get
the exact language for you but that's a
really good point because you're correct
people who experience dementia often are
in this situation where especially in
the beginning throws they are experienc
a lot of anxiety and benefit from
medication and some
therapy other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you
all also signed up to speak is Matthew
Laro from ones Sky Community
Services good afternoon good afternoon
you you did ask for five minutes sir if
you could keep it to three I appreciate
it I think I'm G to keep it very quick
um there's a lot of other voices in the
room that are far more educated uh
personally and and experientially than
myself uh my name is matth cero I'm the
CEO of on Sky Community Services I'm
here representing my organization my
organization only not our trade
Association and not any other Area
Agency in the state so I just want to be
very clear um over the last four years
I've been CEO of on Sky Community
Services we've had um last year we had
14 people come to the ER that had some
coing issues um but we've had five um
individual cases that uh including uh
Miss sanx uh son and another individual
that we have in the the room today um
that could have significantly benefited
from Intervention had this uh language
not been in the
bill um
you're looking at individuals sitting
languishing in emergency rooms and not
because the hospital doesn't want to
provide the care not because the mental
health services um Center can't do it it
it's just purely for the fact of this is
what the course of business is as an
area agency we contract with our
community behavioral mental health
center uh we have a memorandum of
understanding we work very well with
them this would give us the flexibility
and ability to do better work and to
prevent people from having to languish
in emergency rooms to get them into the
um services that they need uh by having
the support and medical interventions
that are necessary
um we're lucky um my region is very um
we have a very good meal Community
Mental Health Center they work with us
they're Li they are the system itself
into representative M's uh point of view
they're they're over tax they don't have
the the funding and they don't have the
Manpower um to really even meet the
needs that that they have right now but
what this does is it uncuff us allows us
to work work hand inand um to be able to
provide the services that need to be
provided um so that we can close this
Gap and move forward um there's some
other language that's being suggested um
in the in the s best way I can describe
it um I would suggest keeping it simple
so that the greatest amount of people
can be included into to this bill um
because we have indviduals with
developmental disabilities intellectual
disabilities um or you know just
different varying challenges Trauma from
brain
injuries um um there's just a lot and
the list could be endless you can
exclude someone inadvertently or or not
um so I I would just caution that you
keep it as broad as
possible but thank
you thank you any questions
representative anagel thank you Mr
chairman thanks for taking my question I
absolutely love my job because all my
patients are tweeners they don't fit
into cubby holes and I that's basically
why we're creating models of integrated
care which I think may be a solution to
this but I really struggle with that
first paragraph and I wanted your
opinion I I really don't think it's
necessary to strike out in I understand
why you want to do it but I think it's a
mistake to do strike out the
intellectual disability but I would
really rather focus on that last line
kind of paragraph
two um that you can't I think it's sad
that it needs to be in there but I
understand why the comorbidity point you
can't deny people and I'm just curious
what you think about that I I think you
should strike the the verbiage and I
speak from a practical standpoint the
majority of my job is fighting with
people um which is great because I'm
contentious in nature so um but
realistically um fighting with hospitals
fighting with you know whoever um and
sometimes it's fighting with the
hospital to fight with someone else in
order to get the care so we can get them
out of the hospital um which by the way
I I I say this but I I want everyone to
be very clear in my opinion the New
Hampshire has one of the best hospitals
in associations in the country and I've
worked in a lot of different states I
love my partners we just vary on
different subjects at different times um
but they are great to work with it's
just we're all very strong willed people
um but not having having that verbiage
in there would be a significant benefit
to this population um and it it doesn't
seem like it's a very large change and I
can understand why you would want to
keep it in there but I I can tell you
it's the people you deal with on a
day-to-day basis um this is where they
get triggered into taking these
indefensible positions and it will take
me three to five days to get to the
right person who then will come in and
weigh in and say we should do this or
shouldn't um or it'll take another 3 to
five days beyond that person to get to
maybe the CEO of the hospital or maybe
the CEO of the mental health center um
it it's there's a lot of built-in
unnecessary waste delay in time and if
we can get in there get the
stabilization Services necessary we
would probably prevent a lot of people
from languishing in emergency rooms we'd
prevent a lot of people I mean one of
the states in uh or attorney Sanic
didn't mention was Florida we sent a lot
of people to Florida and if anyone was
watching the enhancer Chronicle here's
my plug um we did a uh we were able to
get a person that was in um a hospital
for two years out of their emergency
room um it took us a year to save for
the home we had to buy it we had to
staff it we had to get it all fitted up
um we can work to get all this stuff
done but you know roadblocks need to be
taken out of our
way follow up so are you suggesting that
this verbiage will allow will will no
longer allow certain people to stop they
can't pass the buck anymore essentially
that's and that's been my experience
other people may have varying
experiences in in communication that's
why I make the disclaimer this is my
region my region alone and only me um
but and again I can't express my
gratitude for the partners that we have
we have a great system of Health mental
health care we have a great system of
Health Care in our state um this just is
a crack that we need to fill and it's a
very easy
one in my opinion so representative
wber thank you I keep looking at the
words here and you know keep the more I
read the more I see so uh looking at
lines 19 through
21 um I I took into account the
suggestion of taking out the double
negative and having that read an
individual shall not be denied Services
Under this chapter on the basis of
co-occurrence and it says mental illness
and it does have an intellectual or
developmental disability already in
there although it's not in the upper
part because it wasn't there to begin
with um my question is do we need to add
um the acquired brain disorders in there
uh so or am I just making things too
complicated I know you started out by
saying keep it too s keep it simple no I
if as you get to know me better I love
to over complicate things I so
um my problem is I have not personally
had the experience with an ASD um person
acquired uh prior brain disorder um or
AB ABD person um we're trying to get
them services but I
have I've heard of issues um and I don't
want I bring that up but I don't want to
color that with that was someone else's
like I don't want to speak for any other
regions let me be very clear of that um
so I guess strike that part of the
testimony I'm sorry fair fair enough
thank you other
questions saying none thank you thank
you
all also signed up to speak is kraton
Ward from Abel New
Hampshire and you've asked for three
minutes hi um thank you chairman
McDonald and representative Bernardi um
my name is kraton Ward and I am speaking
on behalf of Kristen Evans who is the
director of policy and advocacy for AEL
New Hampshire AEL is a disability
Justice organization and we are a
nonpartisan nonprofit organization that
fights for the civil and human rights of
children and adults with
disabilities as a disability Justice
organization committed to advocating for
the rights and inclusion of individuals
with intellectual disabilities we
strongly support House Bill
1028 this bill is a critical step
towards addressing the systemic barriers
that individuals with intellectual
disabilities face when accessing Mental
Health Services in New Hampshire
currently the exclusion of intellectual
disability from the definition of mental
illness within the state's Mental Health
Service System perpetuates
discrimination
and denies individuals with co-occurring
intellectual disabilities and mental
illnesses access to vital supports and
services this exclusion not only
contradicts established research but
also undermines the principles of equity
and
Justice research consistently
demonstrates the high prevalence of
mental health conditions amongst
individuals with intellectual
disabilities according to a study
published in the Journal of intellectual
disability research the prevalence of
mental health disorders among
individuals with intellectual
disabilities is significantly higher
than in the general
population furthermore individuals with
intellectual disabilities often
experience unique challenges in
recognizing and expressing their mental
health needs which makes access to
appropriate Services even more
critical denying individuals with
co-occurring intellectual disabilities
and mental illnesses uh access to Mental
Health Services not only violates their
rights but also Al perpetuates cycles of
poverty isolation and
institutionalization without adequate
support individuals with intellectual
disabilities are at increased risk of
experiencing homelessness involvement in
the criminal justice system and other
adverse
outcomes House Bill 1028 represents a
crucial opportunity to align New
Hampshire's Mental Health Service System
with the principles of inclusion and
Equity by removing the exclusion of
intellectual disability from the
definition of mental illness this bill
affirms the inherent worth and dignity
of all individuals regardless of their
cognitive abilities it ensures that
individuals with co-occurring
intellectual disabilities and mental
illnesses have equal access to the
supports and services they need to
thrive in their
communities uh in conclusion we urge
that the members of the committee uh
support House Bill 1028 and take a bold
step in support of disability equity and
inclusion thank
you thank you um your pink card
indicates you have handouts did you have
handouts for the committee or yes I do I
can hand them out sure you can just
thought them around that's
fine are there any
questions representative
Shapiro thank you Mr thank you Mr
chairman um I'm going to ask you the
same question I asked before because I
think you said that as written now this
excludes people with
um with intellectual disabilities from
um from from people identified as me
with mental illness and I
just does it exclude people with
intellectual disabilities or does it
just say that
people who are primarily
affected
whose impairment is primarily caused by
um an intellectual disability should not
be considered mentally ill only if they
have a a co-occurring disorder of mental
illness and intellectual
disabilities um thank you representative
Shapiro for your question um I'm here on
behalf of Kristen Evans the director of
policy at able New Hampshire so I would
prefer to uh share your question with
her and uh maybe she can get back to you
via email or something her email address
is Kristen AEL new hampshire. org so
that's k r y
Sten at abl nh.org
so I've written down your question and I
really appreciate you asking that but
I'd prefer to forward it along to her
and I I would advise the same to anyone
else who's got questions for AEL New
Hampshire thank you very much okay so
you'd prefer no more question questions
at this point yeah I I can't take
questions okay that's fine personally
sorry thank you for being here thank
you also signed up to speak is Julie
Lego good afternoon good afternoon and
again consistent with the others i' I'd
ask you to keep it to three minutes
you've indicated you wanted four but if
you could keep it to closer to three
that'd be great I will do the best I can
good afternoon respective members of
this committee my name is Julie Lego I
am a resident of seab Brook New
Hampshire um a proud social worker
educator and a family member and
lifelong friend of many incredible um
individuals with intellectual and
developmental
disabilities I have worked in various
capacities in the disability field for
the past 24 years most recently since
2012 specializing in Clinical Services
and multi-disciplinary team program
program development for those with
intellectual and developmental
disabilities and acquired brain injuries
and cooccurring mental health needs for
several years I have presented locally
and nationally on topics related to
equal access to mental health care for
those with ID and brain injury I join
you today in support of HB uh 1028 in
um say my career may have come by choice
but my path was one of necessity in 2000
my friends and family members with
disabilities and I experienced a series
of several unexpected
events at the time I was encouraged to
seek therapy to support my adjustment
through such significant loss however my
cousin was unable to access therapy to
process the loss of her mother my friend
was unable to access a therapist to
support the TR tragic sudden passing of
his brother and my two friends who were
sisters were unable to access mental
health supports to add to address the
loss of their brother from the very same
genetic condition that they knew would
someday and have since taken their own
lives all had limited access because of
the presence of their
disabilities this was unfair during
their times of Devastation and truly
discriminatory as they continued to
struggle with access to mental health
care and the years to
follow in my career as a new Hampshire
licensed social worker it is my mission
to ensure that all people regardless of
ability or disability have equal access
to mental health care including informed
assessments from trained Professionals
in my clinical work I support hundreds
of indivi I have supported hundreds of
individuals with co-occurring
intellectual disabilities brain injuries
and mental health needs I receive I have
received multiple calls mon monthly and
sometimes even weekly requesting
advocacy support and accessing Mental
Health Services due to being denied
based on primary
diagnosis according to the National
Association of the duly diagnosed 35% of
those with intellectual disabilities
experience mental health needs as
compared to roughly 20% of the general
American
population for those with ID
co-occurring mental illness is around
40% with persistent mental illness
around
30% those with ID are three to six times
more likely to
experience abuse neglect or exploitation
while the majority of those with ID
experience trauma in their
lifetime I ask you to take that
in it is our responsibility to stop
requiring a focus on primary diagnosis
and allow for our clinical
communities to foster a whole person
approach to care it is imperative that
all individuals regardless of a
developmental diagnosis have access to
mental health assessments and are
supported from a whole person approach
to care all of us have our primary needs
change based on our mental health
symptoms daily stresses Etc we cannot
determine what came first the chicken or
the egg if you could please start
wrapping up yep I ask that we hold our
Mental Health Community responsible for
supporting all people as people based on
their presenting needs I urge you to
vote in favor of HB 1028 to support the
necessary steps in moving towards a
community that supports equality and
mental health services for all New
Hampshire citizens thank you for your
time and
consideration thank you any
questions representative
McKay Mr
chairman I'll try
again you seem to have extensive
experience uh is is there special
training that's different from the
training for people who treat midle ill
patients uh because it it sounds as if
what what you're saying is that
the U Middle health system is not
supportive of
individuals with intellectual
disability can can you define what an
intellectual disability is I think I
know but can can you uh help us that way
absolutely so an intellectual disability
is something that is experienced within
the is um an impairment experience
within the developmental age I could get
into the DSM in in all of the criteria
um but I think that would be a longer
conversation than we we certainly have
time for um however um to go to your
question um about training um uh
attorney senok mentioned about the dmid
to um that is published by the National
Association of the duly diagnosed where
I've had the pleasure of presenting ing
at some of their um national uh
conferences in the state of Ohio a
couple of times um they are that is that
should be um in my opinion um the
standard of care when um providing
Mental Health Services and diagnosing of
mental health conditions for individuals
with uh who experience intellectual and
developmental disabilities it speaks to
um the criter it compares the criteria
of our diagnostic I tool of the DSM 5
which we use um I'm sure you're familiar
from the medical field um but in mental
health we use the DSM um as our
diagnostic tool the dmid um takes into
consideration presentation that would
come from in intellectual disability and
it provides um a comparison to ensure
that we're taking everything into
consideration it helps prevent
Diagnostic overshadowing and that's what
we see in our
population over and over and over again
we label People based on diagnosis ah
it's the intellectual disability it's
the brain injury however our statistics
tell us that people are people and
people with intellectual disabilities
are statistically more likely to
experience mental illness than their
neurotypical peers um we have the right
and responsibility to diagnose with the
appropriate tools be trained on those um
and then also um have trainings and
appreciate you asking further trainings
for our mental health professionals um
to broaden our skill sets so people
aren't excluded based off of talk
therapy Alone um my most beneficial
sessions sometimes have been sitting on
the floor um and providing therapy and
uh we do what it takes for our
individuals thank you representative
Nagel thank you Mr chairman thanks for
taking my question I really appreciate
your testimony thank you I have a
concern that you raised that kind of
reflects what I was talking about
earlier in terms of striking out
intellectual disability and including
that as a mental disability my concern
now is that that will suddenly become an
axis one
diagnosis and wouldn't that un have the
unfortunate side effect of saying um
that oh you have an intellectual
disability we don't cover that we only
cover psychiatric diagnosis so I'm
afraid that that change will actually
exclude these people using DSM criteria
my my very very genuine hope is that
striking the language of intellectual
disability
um if we do not if I'm interpreting this
correctly and I want to pull it out to
make sure that we're they I'm seeing the
same thing you are
um where it states it does not include
impairment primarily caused by
the words primary impairment scare
me they they frighten me to my core as a
clinician there is a significant and as
a family member to be honest and I I
want to be very clear that I am sitting
here not only as a professional but the
first hat and the most important hat I
wear is a a family member and an
advocate I fear the Discrimination that
will continue if we allow people to be
labeled by a primary diagnosis because
that is nearly
impossible to provide to say what came
first and um so I would I'd like to say
that if we were to not strike that
language it is going to allow people to
continue to be discriminated against
based on disability and withhold the or
possibly withhold the ability for them
to even access initial um assessments
that may those initial assessments are
imperative to identify do they have a SE
severe persistent mental illness do they
qualify for services in community mental
health or at Mental Health Centers um I
urge you to maybe think about somebody
who experiences autism and skit um
schizo effective disorder or a a
psychotic disorder um some of the one of
the people that I have treated for a
very long time I can't tell you what's
primary for that person um on any given
day on a very great day and and that
person's taking their
medication he's he's doing fabulously in
autism probably primary that day because
he's stable he's getting all of the
services he needs um he's getting
wraparound Services medications are
going well and he's an active member of
and valued member of his community
however ever when medications are not
stable if he's not consistent in
Services his symptoms of schizo
effective disorder or um any other
psychotic disorder will amplify they'll
exacerbate and in that moment that is
his primary impairment in functioning I
can't tell you what's the overall in his
life primary impairment and functioning
we have to treat them equally and we
need to treat people as
people was set I think so representative
Merchant thank you Mr chairman also
thank you for taking my question as I
listen to these conversations I'm
actually more concerned now than I was
before when I think of autism it's sort
of a
spectrum you can go somebody very high
functioning on autism and somebody on
the other end who's
not is not epilepsy the same way there
are people who have epilepsy who are on
sort of a spectrum too there all forms
of EP epilepsy there are some epilepsies
that really cause tremendous emotional
disturbance for a child sometimes an
adult to the point where they cannot
learn effectively and so forth so why
are we leaving epilepsy in there and not
dealing with that one at the same
time that's a a very valid question um
my experience as a um professional and
loved one is um in the area of
intellectual and developmental
disability I do not have the um
background or education per se in the
medical field which I do feel epilepsy
would be more in the realm of the
medical um so I would be remiss to to
speak to that um directly um medical
conditions certainly have an impact on
Mental Health I see that every single
day um I can tell you that when my kids
don't feel well their mental health
changes when I don't feel well my mental
health changes that is certainly that is
certainly valid um however
um when because I can speak to my
expertise in intellectual and
developmental disability um this is
something that we have seen as a stigma
that has occurred
since well really forever it comes from
that period of institutionalization
where we have been told as long as my
colleagues and I can remember that
people it's disabilities it has the
language has been used people are too
disabled to have mental health needs
they're too disabled to feel those
mental health needs and we know that is
not true um so I know that I'm certainly
going on a tangent separate from your
question um but I can speak to my area
of expertise and I'm sorry that I can't
speak to the medical but um we do have a
responsibility for these individuals who
um experience intellectual disabilities
and autism and brain injury to Advocate
to decrease that stigma
other questions representative Nel U
thank you Mr chairman I figured out what
I wanted to ask and I would thank
representative Merchant for helping me
so my psychology is old that's right but
it's been a bar large part of my career
um I don't use the DSM regularly but my
understanding is that when we make
mental health decisions we're focusing
on access one and so like we can put
autism and epilepsy and all those other
things in axis 3 but those people
commonly have mental health issues as
well so making these
decisions you're using the axis one
definition and we're basically tell
they're they're saying well we're not
going to pay attention the axis one
we're just going to stand around treat
you because the Axis Three my concern is
that getting back to what I asked before
if we strike out intellectual
disability all of the sudden now we're
promoting intellectual disability to an
AIS one diagnosis and they can just say
no we're not going to treat this person
because we only treat psychiatric
illnesses that's my concern is we're
going to make a bigger problem than than
than we've got now that's my big
concern
I I do hear where you're coming from I
would argue
that from my
perspective I feel there is no bigger
problem than blatant discrimination and
I do feel that in the language that is
here right now there blatant
discrimination that indicates that it
will not include people primarily
diagnosed with an intellectual
disability and that says to me not you
not your loved one um and we need to
have people be able to at least access
appropriate assessments so
determinations can be made this language
as it stands prevents people from
appropriate assessment and that is quite
dangerous um from my perspective
other
questions I'm saying none thank you
thank you so
much also signed up to speak is Karen
Turner good afternoon hello uh once
again you've asked for five minutes if
you can keep it to three i' appreciate
I'll TR I mean I prepared it this
testimony all day yesterday I'm the
parent of um what the CEO once said it's
the poster child of this
problem um I just want to um if I do my
job correctly it everyone here will will
see the obvious need to strike
intellectual disability from the
language of the statute um because my
son um is dually diagnosed with autism
some intellectual impairment so
intellectual disability and mental
illness and I was told that by a
psychiatrist and it's been my experience
that people have a hard time
understanding his a his autism looks
really different because of trauma that
he experienced in his anxiety problems
makes him look more autistic and his
trauma his mental illness looks a little
bit different because he's autistic and
it just manifests differently and you
can't really parse out someone's brain
and say this is It's you know 40% autism
or something um uh so I'm just going to
read my statement um I'm the parent of a
24-year-old son who is intellectually
developmentally disabled with
co-occurring mental illness his
designation as intellectually disabled
leads to the denial of mental health
treatment no matter how hard I try to
get him access to Mental Health
Services my son has experienced
psychiatric crises which have led him to
hospital ERS numerous times including
Portsmouth Regional Hospital Wentworth
Douglas hospital exor hospital Elliot
Hospital um conquered hospital and even
a hospital of
Massachusetts um each time his crisis is
triggered by obsessive worries and
stress um despite diagnosis in
documentation of his mental illness he
is diagnosed with obsessive compulsive
disorder and incidentally about 20% of
autistic people have
OCD um my son has been denied access
despite diagnosis the reason because
he's autistic and considered
intellectually um disabled I hope not to
offend you when I say that it feels like
he's being punished continually for the
crime of being an autistic person who
happens to also experience mental
illness I see that the state settled a
lawsuit over acute mental health
patients being held involuntarily in
hospital emergency departments awaiting
treatment my son's situation and that of
other individuals with intellectual
disabilities in psychiatric crisis is
even worse they don't even get deemed
eligible for mental health treatment
they boarded in the ER without any
treatment whether doctors or mental
health CL clinicians nor any help to
know what the next step would be nor any
guidance from staff as to where they go
to get assistance this a very scary
situation for the patient and their
family caused my son great confusion and
pain to see to be stuck in the emergency
department to see other people seeing
Mental Health Counselors and they even
when I asked they would refuse to even
see
him uh even when he was there for weeks
and months at a time my son sits for
weeks other times months waiting
indefinitely so in 2022 he was a month
in conquer Hospital Emergency Department
and in 2023 he was two months in
emergency department at Elliot Hospital
and both times it was refused mental
health clinician and um so I speak from
this personal
experience um ma'am you seem to have
quite a statement there but could you
start wrapping up please um
when when my son was boarding at the ER
um one of the uh doctors paused a zoom
meeting to say we are complicit in this
torture of patients by engaging in a
broken system during another time
barding in in an ER a different doctor
said it's a tragedy that people like my
son don't get the mental health
treatment that they need he'd be too
safe to return home without the
treatment but then nonetheless cleared
because it because he's autistic sick he
would literally never deemed eligible
for mental health
treatment um he was even threatened by
hospital to be taken to him homeless
shelter when he was
boarding I don't know if you can imagine
how much you would suffer as a patient
if you were in psychiatric crisis
feeling unworthy and ashamed that you
can't control your symptoms by yourself
only to be told you have behavioral
problems you need to control in the
meantime you will be left alone sitting
in a room by yourself for weeks thank
again please stop W Please wrap up
months without a chair to sit
in um this is
just this is my son from last week that
I'm talking
about
um let me you kind of threw me off can I
just least get to my highlights I I
prepared yeah please please conclude
though
okay
um
okay hospitals across the state have
dismissed his Mental Health crisis my
son hasn't been able to access
outpatient mental health treatment
either through the mental health system
this is what he needs treatment in order
to prevent these crises in the first
place Riverbend Community Mental Health
Justified their denial of therapy for
his mental illness categorizing him as a
low service utilizer because he has an
intellectual disability in is getting
Services through through the Bureau of
Developmental services but they don't
treat mental illness they do nothing for
mental
illness um he can get medications
psychotropic medications for psychiatric
illness without any problem he's on a
lot of them but he can't get actually
therapy which is everybody knows who in
the field that you it's a combination
that helps people get better you can't
just give people
drugs um in October
20122 my son was living in conquer in a
model called enhanced family care which
is like fer care and he had been um
thriving enough because when we couldn't
get the mental health system to provide
the treatment he needs for OCD my
parents his grandparents paid for out of
patient uh out of pocket for about a
year and he actually got better and
stabilized wasn't going to the emergency
department was actually able to take a
trip to um go to Pittsburgh where his
like hero Mr
Rogers um is from ma'am pleas and then
October 2022 one I'm G to have to ask
you okay one of his providers attempted
suicide in the house while he was home
and it caused him to feel suicidal and
he took himself to the emergency
department and they dismissed his
suicidality because he's autistic then
he attempted suicide the next day it was
sent back there and boarded for a month
and still couldn't get didn't wasn't
considered eligible even after a suicide
attempt and even after having to be
restrained in the emergency mean they
just wanted to send him home but there
was no home to go to because it wasn't
really safe so what so what's happen is
people can I just well hurry please way
over your time okay I appreciate I
appreciate it because it's like I feel
like it's really important you've gone
over the five minutes you've asked for
actually yeah I mean okay well I just
want to say that individuals like my son
who are either like Autistic or in or
intellectually
disabled they have higher mental health
needs and it's and I'm saying it's a
major barrier and the other thing I want
to say is no one's mentioned this I
think this is really important like just
like let's just like talk real what gets
people people's attention is behavioral
problems someone's acting unsafe
someone's a dangerous for other people
and that they can't regulate their
stress properly and that's what happens
and that's what gets them there the
problem is if you're the language in
here makes it easy for the hospital
which they always say that it's
agitation he's having a temper tantrum
even though it's well documented he has
severe trauma ocity and anxiety problems
it does
they just don't want to deal with it
because he's autistic and it's caused
him could could email your statement to
us please ma'am yes and he's been forced
to live out of state he's a he's a he
he's a high school
graduate do we does anyone have any
questions and has worked and volunteered
in his community and now he's forced out
of stay in a group home away from his
family like only because he doesn't get
mental health treatment for being
autistic thank you very much for for
listening any questions
thank you for your
testimony and again if you you're
welcome to submit that to us online if
you I um I did bring some coffees but
okay that's fine if you want to turn
them around that's
fine also signed up to speak is Chelsea
zakone you asked for three
minutes
thank you for giving me the opportunity
to speak here today and good afternoon
representatives and valued members of
the community as stated my name is
Chelsea Zarcone and I am a lifelong
resident of New Hampshire a very proud
603 year I'm here today both as a
concerned and passionate citizen as well
as a licensed social worker and
certified brain injury specialist in
support of HB
1028 I have been supporting those with
co-occurring mental health needs with
developmental disability and or acquired
brain injury for a decade but really
I've been doing it since childhood I
grew up with a friend who was living
with cerebral paly and struggled to gain
inclusion to care and access to Services
the way the rest of his classmates had
as I've continued through my career I've
become privy to significant gaps in
Service delivery to those living with
disabilities specifically gaining access
to support their mental health needs I
speak with family members survivors of
brain injury those living with
developmental dis ability and fellow
professionals with consistency regarding
the Discrimination that people
experience on a daily and weekly basis
in all facets of care across all
settings those living with co-occurring
diagnoses deserve the same level of
access to care as their neurotypical
Piers as it is their basic right a
primary diagnosis of Developmental
disability and or required brain injury
does not exclude someone from
experiencing severe mental illness in
requiring specialized in informed care
designated by their mental health
professionals which is not the
responsibility of the area
agency regardless of our stance
political views or backgrounds we're all
in this room because we want better for
New Hampshire residents in the state we
love as a social worker and human it's
my ethical and moral imperative
imperative to ask today that HB 1028 be
passed as it's a necessary step towards
Equitable access and towards this
betterment I ask today that you the
representatives and committee consider
that if somebody with a developmental
disability and brain injury does not
discriminate is not discriminated having
this diagnosis why should the mental
Healthcare discriminate against them and
to your point representative McKay our
system has come a very long way and I'm
very proud of that for our state and the
ask for this bill is just to continue to
push it forward thank you
thank
you any questions representative
Weber thank you as a brain injury
specialist maybe you're the right person
to have asked the question uh if we pass
the bill as it was submitted to us does
it sufficiently cover the population
with brain injuries or do we need to add
that as a
specific I would say adding it in
specifically and the reason I say that
is because a developmental disability
which includes ID and or Autism is
something that somebody has as
previously stated in their developmental
age however anybody any of us in this
room can experience a brain injury at
any time and the reason I also highlight
it is that individuals with brain
injuries are also served specifically by
their area agencies I have a
follow and do a followup thank you and
if I may follow up what is the specific
technical term that you would recommend
because we've said brain injury we've
said acquired brain disorder and I am
without the technical knowledge to
understand which of those formulations
is the correct one yes um it's a very
good point I would use acquired brain
injury or acquired brain disorder and
the reason that I specify acquired brain
disorder is that the ABD waiver which is
something that people
with an acquired brain injury um some of
there are specifics around it however
um it is something that area agencies
also offer so if we're looking for that
continuity that is language that area
agencies use so acquired acquired brain
disorder yes okay as it encompasses
acquired brain injury as well okay thank
you very much for that that's very
helpful representative
Merchant thank you Mr chairman also
thank you for taking the question
earlier I asked a question about the
diagnosis of epilepsy yes and that also
in a lot of ways like autism is on a
spectrum can you address that as far as
whether we should try to deal with it
it's not a brain injury per se could
lead to one but most of the time it's
not the issue however severe epilepsy
particular in some children cause
problems emotionally and otherwise
correct and I would not disagree with
that at all um my epilepsy as dementia I
know was mentioned earlier there's so
many neurological disorders that fall
into their own category um what I would
be able to extrapolate from somebody
likely living with epilepsy is that they
are going to experience psychosocial
psychosocial challenges therefore
experiencing higher need for mental
health care um further I would say that
removing any sort of discriminatory
language from a bill doesn't do anyone
any harm so being able to provide access
to care to any sort of co-occurring
mental health and whether it's a
physical um or cognitive disability is
just allowing further exclusion to care
for
people representative Seth King oh I'm
sorry
followup thank you Mr chair so following
up on the terminology which I think is
going to be critical here in saying that
is it neurological epy no no just saying
neurological disorders to some degree
because that's what we're trying to get
to with it's going to be brain acquired
disorder epilepsy autism that cuses
interference that's what we're trying to
get to because it's neurological in
nature all of it so as although I'm a
certified brain injury specialist I
cannot make neurological diagnosis I can
make diagnoses under the DSM or the dmid
however epilepsy really falls into a
medical category so I can't really speak
specifically to what you're asking um
again I would really I I don't want to
step out of my role on that however I
would wager to bet again as anybody Liv
living with a co-occurring disorder is
probably more likely um or just likely
in general to be experiencing some
mental health needs at the same
time representative Seth K question for
the chair I don't know if now is the
best time to bring it up or not but um
representative Merchant has asked a
question a couple of times um that I
also was wondering myself and I suspect
others were as well and I talked to
Christina and I I wanted to know um the
history of um AB c and d and why they
were put and when they were put in that
paragraph and she said with your
permission she could get started on that
so that might help elucidate a little
bit what's going on there cuz I felt
like these just seem shoehorned in to
something that was originally there and
i' i' just like to know the history so
sure yeah Christine if you could do that
that'd be great thank
you any other
questions see on okay thank you thank
you also signed up to speak is Chris
Stager to G it's close enough thanks you
know who I'm talking
about and again you've asked for five
minutes sir if you could keep it to
three we'd appreciate it okay my name's
Chris dakus I have a son Kevin who's 30
years old who's profoundly
autistic this is a little snapshot and
uh within its context
um this bill is Kevin is an essential
part of his community since leaving High
school in
2014 Kevin has had a productive day in
home program he had a summer job at Home
Depot for four years he volunteered at
Meals on Wheels for the last eight years
delivering meals to the homebound
clients 5 days a week he had a gym
membership at the YMCA where would he he
would swim laps and use the wellness
center he visited local restaurants
supermarkets and stores throughout his
community he kept to his schedule
throughout the covid pandemic people
always know Kevin by name wherever he
went at home he was always eager to help
when
asked mid January 2023 we brought him to
the Elliot ER with concerns of increased
aggression self-mutilation and strange
body movements we were P told by an ER
doctor they do not admit autistic
patients into the hospital for
psychiatric
treatment at the end of
January we wrote an email to Community
Bridges stating that Kevin was in crisis
and we were in need of support we were
seeking we were seeing more destructive
Behavior including damage to the house
self-mutilation and violence toward
caregivers at home and in the community
we were unable to bring him out into the
community as per usual of his day
program and that that we did for the
last eight years Community Bridges and
Sarah Beamish from Elliot Behavioral
Health recommended that that we called
the mobile crisis response unit to get
an
IA involuntary emergency admission
placement for
Kevin on February 12th the mobile crisis
unit came to the house with the wear
police department and decided that Kevin
did not qualify for an IA placement
because of his
autism on February 15th we visited
Kevin's PCP with our concerns while in
the office Kevin attacked his mother by
punching her in the chest no real
guidance was offered and we were sent
home home on February 16th Kevin became
increasingly violent he was hitting and
kicking his mother as well as slamming
his body into the slider Kevin's mother
called me to make uh me aware of the
situation I called his primary care
physician who recommended that we bring
Kevin to the Elliot emergency room for
evaluation we called 911 and the we
Police Department arrived at the house
with an ambulance and brought Kevin to
the Elliot Hospital emergency room in
Manchester the emergency department
staff placed
Kevin in the PS in psychiatric
evaluation placement P unit that is a p
unit in the emergency department not the
pro not the hospital
proper after several hours at the pep
they decided that it would be
detrimental for him to remain there
because of his aggression and violent
behavior and ask that we bring him
home I felt it was unsafe for Kevin to
be at home and it would also be unsafe
for other family members if Kevin were
at home after several days of being
observed in the P unit they still
refused to admit Kevin into the hospital
for treatment because of his
autism they also cited a law titled RSA
135-can 2 which states that anyone with
an intellectual disability is expressly
excluded from Mental Health Services
because there is a presumption that any
atypical behavior is caused by the
intellectual
disability Elliot Hospital stated it is
the responsibility of the community to
find a safe place for Kevin the state
through Community Bridges declared it
was not their role the hospital and St
and state went back and forth declaring
that neither one knew the other one's
role I demanded a resolution as his
Advocate a social worker at the Elliot
Hospital hit and a supervisor at
Community Bridges both recommended that
Kevin go to the New Hampshire Start
Center I agreed to this because Kevin
was in crisis and her family was under
duress the Start Center turned out to
be a respit facility for adults in
transition crisis the staff at the Start
Center had no expertise with autism and
didn't have the ability to make any
psychiatric or behavioral evaluations
that were not provided at the hospital
we could start wrapping up
sir as his caregivers and Advocates we
continue to seek out Supportive Services
for Behavioral and mental health for
Kevin Kevin's
Behavioral Health Senter referral to
RiverBend Community Mental Health Center
in conquered when we contacted them they
informed us they could not accept Kevin
as a patient due to his lack of
communication skills because he is
severely autistic and non-verbal they
could not take him as a client
additionally uh excuse
me additionally we sought out intensive
treatment services which are provided
for high-risk adults with disabilities
in New Hampshire to qualify for these
Services it requires Kevin to be
identified as high- risk we sought out a
risk evaluation and the state wasn't
able to provide one he was denied access
by a Statewide committee called the
community of practice they stated they
needed documentation which shows that
Kevin's behavior is not rooted in a
medical condition they said we do not
have sufficient documentation of this we
also put in a referral for Applied
behavioral analysis for Kevin we have
been waiting since August for financial
approval from the BDS to start this
service for Kevin Community Bridges has
supported and not resisted policies that
deny mental health rights to Kevin
policies that withhold Services until he
commits a crime and is not that is
nothing less than entrapment
participating in the entrapment a
vulnerable person represents a
frightening culture of misplaced public
trust and unchecked authority authority
and Trust unencumbered by self-analysis
or sound ethical judgment is
unacceptable there are no emergency
crisis services for the profoundly
autistic the Start Center is not an
emergency service one must undergo an
initial intake process it is not an
in-house psychiatric Treatment Center
the emergency rooms in our hospitals
would not admit profoundly autistic
people into the hospital and they openly
say so citing a law en titled RSA 13 5-2
c semicolon 2 a committee associated
with Community Bridges known as
community of practice two
pages determined that there was not
enough documentation to place Kevin in
intensive treatment services they made
this determination despite an extensive
pep report from the Elliot emergency
room years of evaluations IEPs from
various educational and medical
professionals comments by his PC and
numerous reports from from A's parents
we asked Community Bridges to connect us
with a risk assessment
we have been waiting for many months for
the documentation that the community of
practice committee had asked for we are
still not being provided a risk
assessment despite the state providing
no dissenting views reports or
evaluations to counter the paperwork
that the cop rejected the only subst
substantive request was that we provide
medical documentation showing the
behaviors are not a response to a
physical condition since then Kevin had
an anoscopy a CAT scan blood work EEG
ultrasounds and an MRI all of these came
back normal and still there is no
response the state its agents and and
vendors we put in a pro proposal for ab
behavioralist consultant back in August
2024 we asked for four month for four
months until a more complex service
could be provided we never heard
anything about this being approved in
October we requested a more complex
program was just approved for a mere 26
hours I'm on my last page well is it a
full page hold on it's three qus of a
page it's a year if it's a year of
suffering I'm going to take it forcing
parents and caregivers to be
self-educated doctors Educators
behavioralists and psychiatric treatment
facilities for a vulnerable person who
the state public and private sectors
openly openly reject is nothing more
than State sanctioned neglect the state
has not produced any private facilities
that can properly treat and facilitate a
stable environment for Kevin there is no
state run group homes that provide
services the state has no plans to
procure produce or seek to facilitate
the connecting of such Services they
simply put Kevin in a pool of people to
linger In Perpetual condition of State
sanction neglect while the crisis in his
life unfolds furthermore I have been
told on multiple occasions that is out
of the scope of Area Agency to provide
mental health and Behavioral Services
simultaneously it has been determined
that is within the scope and authority
of community to practice to deny the
same this is a double standard like
entrapment of vulnerable people and
state sanction neglect double standards
are not ethically tenable thank you
Chris dagas okay thank you for your
testimony any
questions I'm saying
none I think you covered it pretty
well um I don't know if he wants to
submit the written
testimony or did he I'm sorry if I
missed that when I was coming in from
another meeting my apologies anyway um
in terms of the blue sheet in the back
10 people signed up uh in favor of this
bill the department signed up and took
no position and online 12 signed up in
favor one opposed and one
neutal with that I am going to close the
public hearing on House Bill 1028 and
open the public hearing on House Bill
FN uh and recognize the prime sponsor
repr representative Eric
gager um hi so uh what since it kind of
took a while with the previous one I had
to go out to um plug in my computer to
charge out of the hallway so do you mind
if I run go get that real quick starting
sure
there
yeah
made
all right so um representative Gallagher
you may proceed yeah so I'm
representative Eric Gallagher
representing uh Marat County District 20
which is conquered W 6 and I'm here to
um produce or present um HB
1615 relative to the autism
registry um so um yeah
I so that that previous belill since I
was here listening for it
um has kind of made me uh a little bit
worri about the um terminology I use
here when um introducing this um but
personally the term I prefer to use to
refer to myself is um that I'm a member
of the neuro Divergent Community um so I
I don't actually have um autism myself
I've tested negative for it um multiple
times um which yeah may have you
thinking oh well maybe he does have it
and you know what fine I I don't care if
you think that um just know that it's
not what I think I have or and it's not
part of my diagnosis um so but anyways
um yeah you've got neuro Divergence is
kind of like a larger Spectrum than just
the autism spectrum so being part of
that Community I um often hear people
talking about um different laws relating
to different conditions um within that
spectrum and um one thing I heard about
recently was finding out that we have
have this um autism registry in the
first place um so yeah when I heard
about that I was kind of shocked um to
learn that it existed um and
um yeah my first concern was okay we've
got a state constitutional
um guarantee to a right to privacy does
this
um does this registry comply with it um
so I sent out a research request with OS
um they got in touch with the HHS DHHS
said that yes it does comply um the ru
making they sent though
um seem to contain some information
where I'm not
entirely sure I'd agree that that it
supports their claim that
um it it does actually protect privacy
as well as it could um so I decid all
right I'll I'll just look at the
enabling statute and see what I can
change about it to um improve the
Privacy about it um so
um yeah to kind of go through the
changes um so the first one um replacing
um epidemiologic with sociological um
that's because one of my co-sponsors
when I was discussing it um represented
Foo um wanted to uh make it clear that
uh autism is not a
contagious condition um you know and
epidemiologic kind of has that
implication that it is so we just kind
of wanted to um make sure that people
understand that like it's not an
epidemic um so um yeah um and then for
replacing problem with phenomenon um a
lot of people on the Au and
Spectrum uh would think that their
condition is not actually a problem and
is in fact an um Advantage for them um
so yeah the that wording changes just
kind of
to destigmatize it a little bit more um
um and um yeah kind of reduce the
ableism here um so then the part where
it says the department may enter into an
agreement with an appropriate entity for
the management of the registry
um so that that part kind of concerned
me that um you know because it that's
basically saying that it's not just the
state that has access to this registry
but also potentially
um a thirdparty
uh entity that could have access to it
as well um I mean it does say provided
that any records and data submitted to
the department
pursuant um of this division shall be
the property of the department um but
the thing I was worried about there so
one of my kind of pet issues um is free
and open source software um you know and
open data formats so um you know even if
the department owns the records and data
that those records and data still could
be useless if you don't have the proper
software to be able to read it you know
imagine like imagine if the registry was
kept in hieroglyphics and you didn't
have the Rosetta Stone like that so yeah
basically that's what um the additional
Clause as as well as the software used
to store such data why I think um that
the department Ju Just to ensure that
this third-party entity can't like
change something about the format of it
to um make it unusable to the
department um so the ne next section so
the next part is about what's in the ACT
what is in the actual registry so um I
tried to reduce the amount of personally
identifiable information that's in it um
so uh date of birth kind of had to stay
since um well I'll get to that in the
next section um gender though I didn't
really see a reason for including and
that's a additional source of personally
identifiable information so I thought of
removing that um and then um it mentions
the unique identification code um for
identifying the child um so looking in
the rule making um so apparently the
code is based on the initials of the
child in question um and so it currently
says it it um shouldn't include the name
but to me at least initials are still
pretty close to the name so I think um
it's worth specifying the initials
separately um yeah I um you know if the
the department could come up with some
other sort of unique code that doesn't
involve initials you know come up with
some sort of cryptographic hash or
something instead um and just wanted to
make sure that um none of the other
fields contained that um information as
well um so the next sentence um so one
thing I did while researching this was
to do a comparison of other states that
have autism Registries and one thing I
found that New Jersey had that I think
is actually kind of a positive aspect um
that's worth emulating um is when
someone's entered in theirs they provide
resources to the person who um is and
the F their family um who's being
entered onto it um so um yeah I added a
sentence to um provide for that
provision of resources as well um and
then
um so since this is where the the
amendment I handed around comes in um so
uh also upon discussing this um one bit
of feedback was uh why not add an opt
out mechanism to it um and you know that
I thought that was a good suggestion I
honestly can't remember why I didn't
include that in the first place um but
anyways yeah I thought that the
um opt out form that this would be the
proper place to put that like right
after um with the provision of
information Clause um so in section
three
um
so um I think I think uh
drawing an explicit reference to State
Constitution's guarantee of privacy um
is I mean so yeah the department already
has to follow it but I think saying so
explicitly is just kind of good as a
reminder or a form of Defense in depth
um you know to just really drive them
that this is something that we care
about um so the addition of licens are
certified so
um in the online 24 um so that is um to
if you go back to um the beginning of
section two where it says physician
psychologist and any other licensed or
CER certified healthcare provider um
shall um make this report so um the
addition of those terms is just kind of
to bring the wording in sync and um so
it's in sync in section three as it is
um in section two um
so um cuz yeah the par in section three
is um
basically
a
um basically a grant of um immunity or
divulging confidential information um
which I mean I can kind of see why
that's necessary for it to be provided
in the first place under section two um
but um since the wording is different um
or under current statute um what I worry
could happen there is um you know it
could allow say an unlicensed or
uncertified provider to violate
someone's privacy even though they
technically don't have to under um
section two so this is just kind of to
tighten up that language
there um so the and then the addition of
section five whenever a child reaches 18
years of age the department shall remove
the entry pertaining to the child from
the
registry um so yeah again that comes
from the comparison with the other
states Registries um they the other
states that do have Registries do mostly
have age out mechanisms and um yeah it
doesn't appear that our current registry
has such a magnetism and um yeah if you
just look through the language of the ex
in statute it is constantly referring to
the child as the one being entered into
it so I think that kind of
demonstrates that the um original intent
of this bill um was specifically for
children and not for
adults um so yeah I think that changing
this should help bring that more in line
um
so
yeah that's that's basically um what the
bill does um to address some questions I
received about it one of the most common
is oh well why not just abolish the
registry
entirely um and I
mean that's something I'd be open to if
that's the direction that members of the
community want to go in
um I was just feeling a little bit more
cautious about it and think May okay
maybe maybe there is actually a
legitimate reason for having this um
and yeah um maybe somebody will testify
to that I'm not sure um but
um yeah so what one of my
concerns that um as to why not just
abolish it completely is the part about
the third party entity that could
potentially um be administrating
this registry I'm worried that if we
abolish it improperly we might
accidentally end up just abolishing the
state's copy without also abolishing um
any copy that the third party entity
might have so um yeah I just want to
make sure that we have it fully under
State
control um before abolishing it so yeah
we can make sure we do it properly
um
so yeah that's what I've um got for now
and I'll take questions any questions
representative
Weber my question is actually for the
chair um and we've been piling a lot of
work on Christina Dyer lately but I
would be very she's still smiling back
there I would be very interested in a
history of this legislation because it
actually the registry came in in 2006
which was the year that I was elected so
I have no personal history of why we
have it or what we were trying to
accomplish at the time and I think that
having the background would be very
helpful for us or for me personally uh
to understand just gave me a thumbs up
right whether the whether the registry
is accomplishing what we wanted it to do
and and why we might want to keep it or
not keep it yeah and I I agree that is
something that I wasn't really able to
find out much about myself so um yeah
representative Merchant then
representative Seth K thank you Mr
chairman and thank you representative to
uh bring this bill before us I concur
with what you're saying I there should
be a mechanism to withdraw any
information out of a registry um if the
parent or if the child upon reaching the
age of 18 so desires to do that so I'm
fully in support of that but I also
concur with representative Weber is
trying to understand the history of this
and fundamentally more important than
the
history is the registry being utilized
and if it is is it effective is it
accomplishing what it wanted to
accomplish um so this is something when
with talking with one of my co-sponsors
that apparently I'm representative Theo
looked into a little bit um apparently
the the point is um for doing um
scientific studies with um I mean and I
I think that's kind of they kind of
touch on that
um in section or Roman one um with
enabling Al analysis and facilitating
planning and
services um but uh yeah
from what I've heard is that that hasn't
actually been happening is that
um there apparently there's only been
one um peer-reviewed
study um that has been used the autism
Registries data since it was first
introduced um which yeah that
seems like a fairly small number and
like it's not
really living up to its purpose to me
Al set representative
Merchant representative Seth King thank
you Mr chair and thank you
representative Gallagher for taking
questions I have um I don't have a
device in front of me to look up
definitions um anytime I have a question
about definitions I love to look things
up just to really make things concrete
so maybe somebody else can do this and
later explain to me but you want to
scratch out the word epidemiologic and
replace it with sociological and the
reasoning you gave was that you know uh
autism isn't contagious but I know that
we often use the word epidemic for
things like obesity loneliness epidemic
um and those aren't contagious so um I'm
just wondering if either I or you are
mistaken by what epidemiologic means and
then furthermore um you replace it with
a word sociological which to me sort of
implies cultural not not terribly that's
that's not the best word but um it sort
of almost sounds like it's a choice more
than something that you don't have a
choice and if you use the word
sociological um I could be wrong about
that I'm just throwing that out there um
what are your thoughts on that um so
yeah I think there is um a difference
between referring to things as an
epidemic and the use of the term
epidemia ological um you know I think
when you add theology suffix on there
and um you know talking about in a
scientific
context um that is different from
without that suffix when um yeah with
without that suffix it's a lot um people
are generally a lot Freer to use it as a
metaphor or as figurative language or
something but um adding theology kind of
makes it not quite so much um so um yeah
my intention with um
sociological um replacing with
sociological wasn't to imply that autism
is a choice or anything like that um but
just kind of
to try to come up with a different
adjective that's a little bit more
humanizing for um the people
experiencing um these conditions um you
know
um if if you have an alternative
adjective um that is better than both
epidemiologic and sociological I would
be um open to um
replacing it with that third adjective
instead but um that
is um just the first the first one that
came to mind for
me other questions oh followup it's not
a follow-up but I do have another
question
um you have this part here as well as
the software used to store store such
data now being a free software Advocate
myself I know what that means and I know
you know what that means I'm not sure if
the lawyers would really know what that
means um because it's it's not terribly
explicit saying free software which you
own and you control and you could edit
the source code and all those things um
and I'm and my question is
um so for example Excel is a Microsoft
program I believe and that's a
spreadsheet and and free software
Advocates would use like open I can't
remember what the name of it is open
office or office open Office which is
basically Excel but it's free software
so if they had this registry um my
question is they' probably be required
to use something like open office
instead of
excel but seeing is how it's they're
going to be on computers that are apple
or Microsoft computers they're not going
to be Linux computers would this get
them in trouble because while open
Office might be free free and open
source software the computer uh the uh
operating system itself would not be and
then then it would really get him into
trouble what are your thoughts so so my
intent here wasn't to
um wasn't necessarily to try to free the
entire software stack all at once um I
mean that is something that I've tried
with other legislation but hasn't gone
over too well um with the state it
department so um yeah my intent here was
kind of to kind of keep this limited or
in the yeah most narrow fashion to um
just the software the program um
individual programs such as um yeah such
as open office or Libra office or
whatever and I'd also not note that um R
RSA um chapter
21r uh has some uh definitions of open
data formats so um and o Open Source
software so um I think uh if you need
some more Precision you could um just
draw a CR cross reference to um RSA 21
r10 um to uh make yeah make that a
little bit more
explicit other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you
also sign up to speak is representative
Caitlyn
kutab thank you Mr chairman and
honorable members of the house and uh
Health and Human Services committee for
the record I'm Caitlyn cab representing
Rockingham District
17 I am a co-sponsor on this bill
however I would like to state
that I have gotten so many phone calls
from parents on both sides of the aisle
that really would like to ultimately see
the entire registry just repealed they
have not gotten any value out of it and
many were really angry when they saw the
bill because they had no idea that their
child's data had ever been shared let
alone had they ever consented for it to
be shared and while it is said that
we're hippoc compliant and whatnot I
would like to state that part of the
things that go into this registry
include the last four digits of the
patient social security number as well
as the patient's initials date of birth
their Residence at Birth and their
Residence at the time of diagnosis and
their gender depending on which small
town you're in I know in wiam we have a
list of all the children who were born
in the in the year we get a yearly Town
report if you go through we're a small
enough town and we're not really that
small um you could figure out looking at
somebody's initials who this kid
potentially could be by knowing their
year of birth from this report and then
the year on this
so this was this legislation was enacted
in 2006 we were the second state to put
in an Autism registry West Virginia was
the first there are currently eight
states which which have an Autism
registry in it um it was enacted
to analyze the
autism issue that was happening or
diagnosis to see if there was more
diagnosises what could be done and also
to facilitate the the planning and care
for those with autism however when you
go and ask is anything being done with
this data what positively are we doing
with this
data there's not one example we give out
a yearly report which you can find on
the HHS HHS website which just simply
States the number that were diagnosed
and the age that they were diagnosed at
and also their ethnicity and it gives it
it also gives a report by County so I
guess just aggregating and telling
people how many were diagnosed with a
particular disorder I'm not sure what
value that that's adding it's not
providing any of the other value that it
was initially stated could potentially
add
so I do like the fact that now we're
talking about potentially you know
asking parents for their permission at
least to to to pass on this data I guess
I'm just not sure what the purpose of
continuing on with something that isn't
currently being used for
any beneficial purpose is so my
um opinion would be it would be better
if this was amended to just repeal the
registry entirely I'm happy to take any
questions thank you any questions
representative Nel thank you Mr chairman
thanks for taking my question question I
I'm always interested in hearing about
these Registries that I never knew
existed you know and we had the ALS one
last year I diagnosed ALS I've never
even knew the registry existed so I'm
curious how many people aren't even
being reported at all the other concern
that I had about this process too is
having a child who does not have autism
who is diagnosed with autism merely so
we could qualify for services I'm
curious how much of this information
that goes into this registry is even
accurate um and I'm just curious if you
have any thoughts if that changes your
mind stimulates you to agree with what
your position you just took was
or I think I just made a statement more
than yeah so I'm not sure how accurate
it is either there was many of the
parents when they were upset that they
found out about this they were like well
what if we our child was diagnosed in
Massachusetts is it going to go in there
technically the rule says that if you
were if you were diagnosed in
Massachusetts when you would go back to
your pediatrician here in New Hampshire
your pediatrician should should be
putting it in there how often that
they're actually doing it who knows if
somebody is later found out that this
was a misdiagnosis are they removing it
who knows is there there's I couldn't
find a report on here to remove somebody
I could find the the part where you
input somebody but there was nothing on
the website to remove somebody if say
you put in a person that was later found
out to not have it so I would share the
same concerns as you that I'm not sure
that it's even that accurate
other questions representative South
King thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking questions it sounds like there
are some negative consequences of having
been put on this registry can you
explain that a little bit more in detail
I'm just curious if somebody could be I
don't know denied access to some rights
that are you know standard for everybody
else because they're on this list um can
you go into that at all
thanks so I'm not sure that I'm aware of
most of the people that I talk with
weren't even aware that their child was
on such a list so I have not been made
aware of anybody that was discriminated
against as a result of being on this
list
however I think that there is an issue
of of a privacy concern here and you
don't know what what somebody's going to
do with this data I mean we have data
breaches with different things all the
time so could there potentially be at
some point absolutely especially when
you consider that you're putting the
last four digits of somebody's social
security number and their date of birth
I think it makes it pretty
easy if the right person stole that data
for them to be able to find the person
and do whatever they want with
it other
questions representative
TZ uh thank you for taking my question
um
online um six and seven uh part of the
purpose is to facilitate planning for
services to Children uh and their
families and so are you familiar or can
you describe what kinds of Serv Services
children and their families
receive sure thank you for the question
so I did ask the question in terms of
what is being done for this planning how
is this being used and what I was told
was in the beginning they were trying to
impress upon the fact that early
diagnosis and early intervention led
to much higher success um however that's
already been implemented it's already
part of regular Pediatric
screenings
so in terms of planning for facilitating
things this information like the the
parents address and stuff is not in the
database so you don't have HHS coming
forward and sending the parents
information and saying hey here here's
these resources that are available just
so you know like you can go and see if
if the child's you know under three if
they're eligible for early intervention
if they're over three that they may be
eligible for an IEP at school that's not
happening so it doesn't seem like
any of this actual planning I'm not even
sure how it even could happen since it's
deidentified supposed to be deidentified
data
followup so who do you know who that's
going that information is going to
because I would assume and I could be
completely wrong that it is family
centered early supports and services the
people who you know uh administer the
programming or is it somewhere else like
it's not like it's on the web for
anybody to access it
a specific place that collects the data
for planning purposes so that children
and families can be
served so since you've looked into it I
was hoping you could share yeah so there
is on here like who
um hold on one second I'm trying to see
if I can find it
uh
sure do we have a card from the
Department we do uh uh attorney Williams
perhaps that would be the best coming up
next it does say it's yeah it is shared
with the Department of Ed office the New
Hampshire behavioral developmental
Services the Bureau of family centered
services and the be behav Bureau of
Behavioral
Health um and annual results are are
also published on the
website um so those bureaus are getting
it but I'm not sure how that's helping
to provide services to kids since these
services are often provided by area
agencies or
schools representative
Shapero thank you Mr chairman um
DSM diagnoses are not static they're
changing all the time and they come out
with new additions of the um
DSM frequently so um what was considered
an a diagnosis of autism
30 years ago is not what's considered
diagnosis of autism spectrum
disorder currently so I'm wondering if
you know in the autism spectrum in the
autism um registry how the changing
criteria for diagnosis is taken into
account like who are you supposed to
report thank you for the question so I'm
not sure how you're supposed to report a
change but currently there
are five different categories under the
the ICD code for it so there's childhood
autism atypical autism Asbergers PPD
unspecified and other PDD so I'm not
sure how you I don't I could not find a
mechanism on the website to either amend
data or remove data as I as I mentioned
if you later find out that somebody
doesn't actually have autism I couldn't
find a way to remove that data and
possibly it exists but it wasn't easily
found on the website follow up follow
up I think you did answer my question
that that at any given time like
currently there are specific categories
that are um reportable to the registry
correct okay thank you representative
kofel thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question um on the
FAQ web on the on the website there is
an FAQ this is the DHHS website about
the autism uh Spectrum
registry um there is a question what is
the purpose the the now I apologize I
left the the page have to come back but
essentially it says that the the there
are several reasons to have this but
that the primary reason is to improve uh
is to make sure that we're we're
screening and diagnosing
autism um th thoroughly and accurately
throughout the state um this was passed
in 2006 in your opinion has uh this
screening and diagnosis of autism
improved or or become more standard as
part of the Pediatric Care process since
2006 thank you for the question so I
would say that definitely the screenings
that are going on in the Pediatric
offices
have increased what the number of
questioners that they're asking at the
different developmental stages to try
and screen for things like this so I
would say that it has has much improved
yes but I'm not sure that that's a
result of this registry because that's
something that's more standardized
through the American Academy of
Pediatrics other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you also signed up to speak or Attorney
John John Williams and attorney Melissa
namoth from the Department of Health and
Human
Services good afternoon members of the
Health Human Services LLY Affairs
committee for the record I am John
Williams I am the director of
legislative affairs and with me is uh
good afternoon Mr chairman and members
of the committee my name is Melissa nth
also from the Department of Health and
Human Services and what I'd like to do
is take um a three prong approach one to
explain the bill on its face uh to give
you some information uh around the bill
number two would be some thoughts and
Impressions about the discussions that
have happened and options for this
committee to take and number three just
recognizing in the audience the prime
sponsor for the underlying bill that
created the registry uh former
representative John jooy is actually in
the room and submitted a pin card and
we'll be able to provide you with some
I'm sure robust history going back to
2006 and the development as to where we
are currently um the department did
submit its fiscal analysis to the
legislative budget Assistance Office on
January 4th it was just right after the
New Year's and you folks were getting
ready for a wonderful session uh and
because they're just so overwhelmed with
the amount of work they weren't able to
turn around the fiscal analysis for your
consideration I would represent to you
that the bill under the four corners of
the document would not represent at
least to the department any change we
would certainly be able to make these
changes We Believe with current and
existing resources however there could
be an impact to the provider Community
because currently there's an additional
requirement that they otherwise wouldn't
have from a technical standpoint and
again I'm just working off the bill in
case you do decide to move forward with
the bill as it was presented to and as
introduced uh one of the concerns that
was raised in the uh fiscal analysis
that we wanted to bring to your
attention and also the sponsor and
co-sponsor attention is on line nine and
10 of the bill when it discusses about
the property of the department to
include also not only the data which is
under current law but also as to the
software used to store such data um if
we were to contract out on that piece we
would probably find it very difficult
that a vendor would want to assign that
property interest to the department and
I would represent to you right now that
we're currently not working with a third
party which was a very good question
raised by by the committee so that would
be a concern with that section in terms
of hampering our ability if we were to
contract out currently this is all being
done inh house within the department and
utilizing primarily the Exel uh does go
back to 2006 so we utilize those tools
that are out there and currently utilize
that same but I'm sure like everything
evolving that will do exactly what I
think that represent Seth King was uh
was referring to um the other item is on
line 23 uh under the um paragraph uh
three of the current law there's a
provision that adds in accordance with
the New Hampshire state constitution
guarantee of privacy we we do not take
exception to that but we would like add
it if it the bill is to go forward for
to include or any other provisions of
law because that's really important to
include that as well if you're going to
qualify specifically where the source
for protecting the confidentiality of
the information um comes from um this
may surprise you um we actually came to
a very similar conclusion as the sponsor
and co-sponsor about the viability and
the need for the registry it is very
very important that we care uh very much
about all of New Hampshire's population
particularly those who have been d
diagnosed with autism and through our uh
Bureau of long-term supports uh and
Bureau developmental Services we do
contract with area agencies to provide
those services and under the definitions
to qualify for those services for uh
disa uh Disability Services autism is
one of those areas so we actually
believe constructively that much of what
this bill was trying to much of what
registry rather is trying to accomplish
is actually happening in real-time
practice in terms of identifying
children who have been diagnosed with
autism and providing them with those all
important services for developmental
Services the other thing is the question
is start wrapping up yes I will wrap up
importantly um so the department of Ed
maintains statistical data on autism we
need to and I would suggest that uh
through working with your committee
researcher working with the Department
of Ed to explore what they're currently
already reporting so if you go to the
Department of education's website under
special education they provide data as
it relates to ODS
it likely is either coming from the
individual education plans the IEPs or
from data that's coming from the school
sources so you are getting that all
important data perhaps from another
location so that raises a question about
duplication of efforts and thank you for
your Indulgence because I really think
this is an important point for you to
make some progress on this legislation
is that it is probably likely that this
is actually outl its usefulness uh for a
very different reason than perhaps uh
because we do Safeguard information we
feel very strongly about that but um it
doesn't serve you well to having two
sources of uh data and information on
the same subject matter and we would
agree to explore the issue of either
repealing or abolishing this might make
some sense so whether you put this bill
into interm study or allow a couple of
weeks to hold on this before exing out
for perhaps an amendment so that you can
further explore what the department of
Ed does provide for data around autism
because we certainly support the
services through those diagnosis so at
least we're accomplishing that all
important end of it so at the end of the
day hopefully I didn't surpris you so
much by saying we agreed for very
different purposes I have to go on the
record with the sponsor and the
co-sponsor for the bill and wanted to
thank them for bringing these issues
before this
committee representative Seth King a
procedural question for the chair um if
we were to um put an amendment to scrap
the registry Al together would that be
considered germine and would we be able
to do that um without another public
hearing or would there need to be
another public hearing with the Germain
Amendment you don't need a public
hearing you don't need hear um and to
follow up on that question would it be
fair to uh put forward an amendment like
that and then not allow anybody from the
the community come and speak on it
because right now we got a public
hearing um that's fairly benign but if
we were to put something forth like
scrapping it um nobody from the public
would be able to come and defend the
program so to speak so I'm just curious
what your thoughts and I would like to
know what representative Weber's
thoughts on that would be um as well
representative Weber
having seen any number of times when um
a committee has taken a bill on a
particular subject and changed it to
exactly 180 degrees opposite of what the
uh Prime sponsor intended I would agree
that it's a Germain issue and I will
remind people that at a minimum if
that's the route that the committee
decided to take there is a whole new set
of hearings in the body which must not
be named
so people who suddenly said you did what
would have a significant and and real
opportunity to go and say this is why
you shouldn't and the other body would
be telling us about that so I would be
comfortable without a uh another public
hearing but it's a good point to
raise any other questions representative
Nel thank you Mr chairman thanks sir
taking my question I just have a
question how much does it cost to
maintain this
registry that is a question we will have
to take back I don't know I was not
prepared for that question I'm sorry but
to give you the the idea we are talking
about getting the information from the
various provider communities and putting
it on an Excel spreadsheet so it's not
an overly I mean we we meet the letter
of the law but it's not an overly robust
what you would think in terms of uh
significant cost associated with if you
were to repeal it so there would not be
a very large sum of money we would love
to think that that we could utilize in
other places but I don't think that
would be the case and because it's on
the department it's it goes on the
department's website it goes to the
department maintains it all it's not
through any thirdparty vendor um I don't
know that there actually is a way to
determine a cost we can certainly look
into that but because it's something
that the department operates on its own
systems already I don't know that we
could identify a specific cost but what
I could say to to the chair is that if
this bill were to be hypothetically
amended to include a repeal and the full
body did vote on that then the
department would be required providing a
financial analysis specifically in the
four corners of the repeal and what
those costs might be in terms of cost
savings other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you very
much also signed up to speak is Chase
eagleson from
nhcd and you've asked for two minutes
thank you chair McDonald thank you for
taking my testimony my name is Chase
seagullson I am the policy and planning
coordinator for the New Hampshire
Council development disabilities we are
a federally funded state agency mandated
by the Americans with Disabilities Act
so I'm going to start with my stance on
the bill as is uh because that's what we
wrote testimony for we have testimony
going around from our director of policy
and planning as is we like the bill uh
we like it better with uh representative
Gallagher's amendment to allow parents
to opt out I can't as for now take a
stance on repealing the bill because we
haven't looked into that
enough uh but if it's defunct as uh the
attorney said it might be then then it's
defunct and there's no point in getting
two uh the same source of information
from two different
places U I'll try to be short and uh
short and sweet so that's all I have for
you oh okay
any
questions seeing none thank
you also signed up to speak is Joseph
aof and you've asked for three
minutes I will also try to be brief good
morning uh my name is Jessica goof and
I'm here today speaking as a member of
the public I also in support of hb650
um with the conversation of getting rid
of the registry altogether I would also
back that um actually would back even
more so uh this bill I think is a step
in the right direction to ensure that
folks who are diagnosed with autism do
have the right to privacy in the state
we know that historically folks with
disabilities have been mistreated by a
variety of governmental bodies and
there's a warranted fear in the
community of getting assessed I know in
this original bill it did seem like the
intent was to track youth but there are
a number of adults I know in the
community who are avoiding seeking
diagnosis because they as an adult don't
want to be added to the registry um I
will say that in New Hampshire it's my
understanding that there are not any
autism specific um resources for adults
they are um included through the um area
agencies and so it would be my
understanding that other sources of data
um would be just as
helpful uh it's also important to note
that the current registry um doesn't
involve consent I know that Hippa uh
doesn't necessarily cover the government
um but again I would say autism in this
way is being treated as different than
any other diagnosis for some reason if
someone's diagnosed with schizophrenia
they're not added to a registry if
someone's diagnosed with ADHD they're
not added to a registry it's just just
autism and that really plays into I
think a fear especially that that was
happening in the early 2000s around um
autism being an epidemic of some sort um
that needed to be tracked specially and
I think we've come a long way in
realizing that it is another
developmental disability um it isn't an
epidemic or something um that needs to
be um a fear and so I will say with the
current registry they are tracking more
information than is required in the bill
specifically in the area of your Social
Security number um and again it's a
small state so in New Hampshire if
someone gain access to that information
it would be really easily identifiable
again last four of your Social um your
phone number your birthday that enough
in New Hampshire um is is that um I I'm
happy to hear that the DHHS does keep
that information in house I know a
source of concern was any third parties
that might have access to that
information so I was glad to learn that
um again I am definitely behind getting
rid of the registry completely but I
think this bill even as is would be able
to get us in the right direction um we
know that autism isn't necessarily a
problem it's a phenomenon and people
with Autism do deserve equal protection
under the law that's what I have thank
you thank
you any
questions seeing none thank you awesome
thank
you also signed up to speak is Don
dejoy
you don't indicate how much time you
need but three minutes would be perfect
for
us thank you Mr chair members of the
committee for the record my name is John
dejoy I am a lobbyist but I'm here
representing myself uh specifically U as
the prime sponsor of House Bill 1709 in
2006 there have been a number of
questions about what why this bill came
forward what the use of this bill is is
it still useful uh I'd like to explain a
little bit about that and then try to
answer questions it's I didn't never
expect it 18 years later to be talking
about this bill again nor did I expect
one of my students from UNH to be
testifying before me so this uh this
truly is a New Hampshire
moment so when this bill was filed it
was filed for the Autism Society of New
Hampshire it was a group it was a
parents group who um represented their
children uh who were dealing with autism
and were trying to expand services for
the autism um for folks affected with
autism it was not contemplated at that
point that autism was an adult disease
it was contemplated in 2006 as a
childhood disease it was also
contemplated as having any type any
number of Nefarious
reasons for its cause if you remember
back to 2006 one of the primary theories
was that uh mercury in vaccines is what
was causing
autism that was the intent of this bill
it was never to provide services to
individuals it was to permit the
department to gather data so that the
department could see the any growth in
uh the number of people affected with
autism to be able to prepare Services
RIT large to Pro to provide what was
needed for the
community the other piece of this was
that it was hoped that this data would
be available to
researchers you know the issue with data
is once it goes by you can't go
backwards and collect data very
easily so the the idea at this in 2006
was to collect as much data as we could
to permit researchers to have Ro a
robust understanding potent hopefully of
the cause of autism clearly the
manifestations of um the condition but
hopefully ultimately the cause I
understand we still do not have a cause
today for
autism it maybe there isn't one that we
can easily
identify but I think the data is as
important today as it was 18 years
ago the committee this
committee took great pains to project
confidentiality not only because it was
the right thing to do but because it was
a room full of parents whose children
had autism the parents knew their
children would be on this registry and
they wanted to make sure that their
children and any other children would be
protected from
disclosure um I'm comfortable that we
did a pretty good job back
then I think the bill before you
suggests that there's ways it can be
improved and that's great um but Jael
car had to approve all the
rulemaking and so I'm comfortable that
gel jel car complied with the statute in
terms of how far the department could go
in making rules um to Mr Williams point
that Doe may have this data as well as
DHHS what I said to him before the
meeting is I don't have a vested
interest in where this data is tracked
what I have a vested interest in is that
this data is tracked anonymously fully
anonymously and that it's available for
researchers that hopefully will continue
to work on a greater understanding of
autism as well as how best to treat it
please start wrapping up yeah um with
that I I think I can just end my
comments um and I'd be happy to answer
any questions thank you representative
Shapiro thank you Mr chairman I'm this
is a curious situation where um
where so 18 years ago we had parents and
advocates for people
um with autism coming to ask for this
and now um we're having the people
who've spoke but they also referred to
people calling them and getting calls
about advocates for Advocates and maybe
parents of people saying we want to get
rid of this so what would you say that
says about the evolution of our
understanding of autism and um the
acceptance of that as a diagnosis and um
how far we've come in terms of providing
services for these things thank you for
the question I think what I would say is
that the information that was presented
is anecdotal so we don't know if it's
one person or dozens of people I think
to the extent I think we have evolved in
our understanding and acceptance and
treatment of autism I think one of the
reasons we've involved and I I don't
know I mean this there's no evidence
that this registry caused some of the
understanding but certainly the registry
is correlated with a greater
appreciation and public acknowledgement
um of
autism I think if it would be
unfortunate just like it would be
unfortunate if we chose to abolish the
cancer registry or we AB chose to
abolish any
registry I think the data is V vital and
we cannot go back easily to recreate the
data I do think we have to go to Great
pains to protect people's anonymity as
we would in any
scientific
inquiry I don't know that opting out of
the registry or removing your name at 18
um benefits the scientific
inquiry but I think assuring the
confidentiality certainly does
other questions representative
Merchant thank you for taking thank you
Mr chairman thank you for taking the
question I we heard earlier Le I did
anyways that there's data that's
apparently available publicly that
doesn't ensure
confidentiality so I'm not sure how the
rules are written by I get through Jael
car but that is definitely a concern can
you speak to that um because going back
to it if the goal was confidentiality to
remain anonymous but there's data on the
website that can drill down to someone's
level of detail that sort of doesn't
remain
confidential I can't speak to the data
that's presented now I haven't looked at
it recently I can speak to what I heard
before which may have been a little
different than what you heard um and I
don't know what the what is more
accurate what I heard is that two
different things were being conflated
that there is data available that should
be in aggregate not in
specific the other piece was that people
at the same time were talking about the
information that is provided by
pediatricians on the registry
form which would include um other
information now the social security
number to the best of my knowledge was
never specified as a data field to be
collected um it was always intended to
be a fully
um to be a a unique Ida that could not
be tracked back to the individual that
was the
intent other
questions representative Nagel thank you
Mr chairman thanks for taking my
question I you brought up a very
interesting point about the 18-year-old
thing and that that really troubled me a
lot I mean if we want to collect data we
really want want to know where these how
autism is affecting people over the
entire scope of life not just before
they turn 18 and I'm just curious what
your thoughts are about that addition to
this amendment to this bill I have that
as well as gender circled as things that
should be should remain in the registry
to the to the extent that the registry
remains I think both of those pieces of
information should
remain you know I I think
it's data is important data is how we've
learned I mean you're a doctor data is
how we've learned about disease and how
we've eradicated disease how we've dealt
with um epidemics in the past this was
an epidemic in 2006 this was an epidemic
of our boys who were disproportionately
diagnosed with
autism people didn't understand why
didn't know where it came from didn't
know how to fix it and at that point
we're talking about fixing
it I don't know what's happened with the
data as far as research but I think it's
still as vital today as it was 18 years
ago representative
Weber would you agree with me that the
concern with data is when you start
self- selecting in one way or another
the data becomes much less useful in the
aggregate to give
us a clear picture of what's going on
out there so that once you
start allowing people as I think we
should to choose whether their data goes
in whether their data stays how the and
all of that does that not make the data
by definition less useful as data than
it would be if we were fully
reporting thank you for the question
representative it does and in fact in
research it makes it frankly misleading
because researchers will come to um
findings that they will believe to be
accurate but because of the data set
they would be wholly
inaccurate other
questions saying no other questions
thank you
okay I have no other pink cards no one
else has signed up to speak on hp1 1615
FN two people did sign the blue sheet in
the back in support of the bill online
uh nine have indicated they support it
and two indicate they oppos it so I'm
going to close the public hearing on hb1
1615 FN I'm going to open the public
hearing on HB
1482 and at this time I'll recognize the
prime sponsor representative Gearhart
thank you members of the
committee representative Jason Gard
representing Franklin Northfield marac
25 I understand you guys are only an
hour and 15 minutes behind schedule so
I'll move
quickly this bill would allow for the
sale of blood and organs in the state of
New Hampshire without government
interference currently we are allowed to
sell plasma sperm eggs hair breast milk
bone marrow stool rent space on your
skin via tattoos or other advertising
participate in clinical trials which
might just turn out to be deadly you can
rent your womb as
well I would like to just read a very
just some excerpts from an article that
a supporter wrote in favor of this
legislation that I think is interesting
and highlights some topics that may not
be uh immediately apparent there is an
there is a per ual chronic blood
shortage since I'm an no negative blood
type universal blood donor and cytom
megavirus negative a disease that most
adults have been exposed to but is fatal
if babies are exposed to it I am
constantly bombarded with emails from
the Red Cross soliciting my blood
fortunately I don't ate my blood as
often as they allow me to but not
everyone is like me in fact most people
are not according to the Red Cross only
3% of eligible people donate blood and
only 7% of people are O Negative with a
guarantee that most of these people do
not donate and are likely not cyto virus
negative as a result is a coin to us
whether or not a newborn will obtain
life-saving treatment since there is not
enough time to test a newborn's blood
type ahead of time how do we solve this
the best way to provide additional
incentives for eligible people to be
able to donate their blood imagine if we
can only eat food from Farmers that
donated their time and labor to produce
it that is a situation we are now in
with blood by allowing people to be
compensated for donating their blood we
could readily inre increase the supply
especially if people are paid more given
their blood type or eligibility imagine
what parents would pay to have their
child's life saved instead of having to
exclusively rely on donations which are
severely insufficient also do not expect
purchasing blood in this instance to be
prohibitively expensive with minimal
government barriers to entry many people
will donate which will substantially
increase the supply and allow for a
reasonable market price for blood
Americans are already allowed to sell
their blood plasma and sperms there's no
reason they should not be allowed to
sell their whole blood and or other
blood products for money while some may
argue there are ethical implications
being with being able to legally sell
your blood and or organs I assert that
the real ethical violations are
manifested when the government imposes
barriers against being able to do this
not only does it make organs and bloods
uh blood less available to people that
are in chronic need of them it also
implies that other people own your blood
and your organs since they are allowed
to tell you what you can and cannot do
with them this is a form of tacd slavery
that should not be allowed allowed to
persist in the 21st century if you value
Freedom or would like to improve the
survival of babies and chronically ill
people you agree that is time to end is
prohibition on being able to do what you
want with your own body to help others
with an added
incentive and I just like to add that in
2017 the hill ran an article where they
discussed that the Orange County
District Attorney's Office in Southern
California prosecuted Planned Parenthood
business partners D Vinci biosciences
and DV biologics who signed a $7.8
million settlement in which they were
banned from doing business in state of
California ever again admitted to
Breaking state and federal laws by
selling a board aborted fetal organs and
tissues from Planned Parenthood for
profit so organs are already being sold
that's not a question the question is
who is benefiting from it and it's not
the people who actually own those organs
so that's where this comes down to and
the last thing is the New Hampshire end
of life options act hb1 1283 was
recently
introduced and this is the medical Aid
in dying it's allowed in 10 states in
the District of Columbia so you're
allowed to and it's being proposed to do
it in New Hampshire you're allowed to
kill yourself but you can't sell your
kidney I think we got to go back to the
the old adage my body my choice and you
should be able to do what what what you
wish with your body since it's your body
and the government does not own your
body so that's all I have to say and if
anybody has any questions I'd be
interested answer them if I can
representative Seth King thank you Mr
chair and thank you representative for
uh taking questions uh I'm with you 100%
on the whole being able to do this sort
of thing there's a book I think that
came out a while ago called when
altruism isn't enough it's been a long
time I I never read the book and I'm not
sure if I'm even right on that but
basically the idea is that there's a lot
of people that um could really benefit
from this that are dying every day and
there are people that could benefit from
selling an extra kidney that they you
know they're they're not inclined to go
give it away and go through the
procedure and all that but um for a
healthy price they probably would and
that could benefit a lot of people both
parties um but I'd like you to talk a
little bit about your bill because um
while you made the the case for the the
philosophy um you didn't speak on the
bill too much um one of the things I
like to do at least in in my world is um
when I see a problem the government has
created I like to find those lines of
code and just delete them as opposed to
making new lines of code and what I see
here is you know it looks like there's
new lines of code being added here
I'm I'm just a little confused why you
know section c we're talking about
testing of cannabis therapeutic can and
then all of a sudden it's talking about
blood and organs uh I'm just I'm just I
don't know I'm just curious why those
two are together like that and and
couldn't couldn't we just scrap lines of
code as opposed to making new ones thank
you sure the simple answer is I'm a
carpenter so I actually trust in OS
which is a many times that goes south so
this bill is in your hands in the
committee and I am that's actually a
really good point don't add simply take
away so I'm totally on board with that
however you guys wish to make this
happen that would be awesome that's
that's what I'll say on that other
questions so no other questions thank
you thank
you also signed up to speak is Alex
Glazer from the New England donor
services and you've asked for four
minutes I'll try to tap it to three if
you could please yes absolutely thank
you good afternoon I'm Alex
Glazer I'm the president and CEO of New
England donor Services we are the
federally designated nonprofit organ
procurement organization responsible for
coordinating organ and tissue donation
for transplant in New England and New
Hampshire and we oppose House Bill 1482
I'm going to just pick out four points
number
one the system of transplant is designed
to maximize life-saving transplant and
ensure safety each donated organ is
medically evaluated for transplant and
this includes extensive medical
evaluation the donor's history
Diagnostic Imaging corology testing you
notice the lab provision there to
identify infectious disease Blood and
Tissue typing to ensure that the organ
transplant will be safe for the recip
reent and also in the case of living
donation for the donor so uh organs that
are from deceased donors are then
determined medically suitable for
transplant if they are they're offered
to waiting patients that are a
biological match another key part of the
national oversight here through the
transplant surgeon according to the
National transplant weight list by the
organ procurement transplant Network and
this is operated by the US Health and
Human
Services um this is a well regulated
system it continues to grow
transplantation which is important for
you to know nationally 2023 was the 13th
consecutive year in a row for donation
and Transplant increases here in New
England and in New Hampshire new records
were set last year for organ donation
and Transplant 52% increase from 2022 so
this is not a static system it is a
dynamic one that continues to grow the
second reason is that this bill would
compromise transplant patient safety
this bill would open the door do
literally in New Hampshire for
unregulated private sale of organs
between individuals from anywhere
nationally or internationally there's
nothing in here that would prevent
individuals coming in to sell their
organs or individuals coming in to buy
organs this kind of rules free market
for deceased and living organs would
create substantial medical risks both
for living donors and for transplant
recipients that would not be subject to
the extensive medical screening I just
already mentioned uh it's not even clear
if these and paid organs would be
subject to uh the criteria mentioned for
health and safety or even that they
would need to be performed these
transplants would need to be performed
by a licensed physician number three
unregulated organ markets are unethical
and one thing to point out here that
unlike blood or semen or human milk
organs do not regenerate so we're
talking about kidneys primarily are what
are donated and living donors that
donate their kidney do not grow back an
additional kidney this is very very
different and it should be treated
differently in policy there's a real
potential for physical exploitation
exploitation of vulnerable individuals
who could be coerced into selling their
body parts for financial gain this could
create a perverse market system where
body parts of the poor become
commodities for the rich to gain
preferential access to lifesaving
transplant the market price completely
unregulated would look pretty different
for someone who is destined ude than
someone who has a well-paying job who
might not be incentivized by the same
dollar amount so this unethical
Confluence of pressures could literally
make New Hampshire the international
epicenter of human organ trafficking and
I say that because there are no states
in the US and only one nation in the
world that has laws that allow for the
buying and selling of organs and that
nation is
Iran it has a regulated not an
unregulated market and there are wide
spread reports of coercion in Iran both
for the donor being coerced into selling
and also the recipient where the
recipients uh are sometimes held hostage
right before the transplant surgery
where the donor then Demands a higher
dollar amount in order to go to the
O so the fourth and last point I have is
that this is preempted by federal law
and current New Hampshire law so the
United States Congress and New Hampshire
have already determined that private
commercial markets don't serve the
interest of donors or recipients uh the
national organ transplant act
specifically and clearly prohibits the
buying and selling of organs and would
prevent would preempt HB
1482 and New Hampshire's own state law
at chapter 291a which codifies The
Uniform Anatomical Gift Act which is a
uniform state law that's been passed in
every state in the country also forbids
sales and makes it a felony so in
conclusion the process of organ donation
is really medically complex it involves
numerous well-regulated institutions
working in concert with trained
professionals it has to be accomplished
in critically short time frames and that
that the organs that are donated need to
be recovered and transplanted quickly
for medically suitable donors in order
for life-saving transplant to be
successful our system is founded on
ethical principles to ensure voluntary
participation and donation and these
Frameworks have served to make our
system medically safe
ethical efficient but importantly also
constantly improving for the patients in
need I'm happy to take any questions
representative
Shapiro yes thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for taking this question could
you um get to us um the uh a link to the
federal laws that preempt this kind of
law absolutely and followup followup um
you spoke about organs which which is um
your purview obviously but do you have
anything to say about the other part of
the bill that would include blood and
blood products I would just say that
unregulated markets are unprecedented in
the medical community and there are
important health and safety regulations
that need to be
considered other
questions seeing n thank you thank
you
also signed up this speak is zephen
wood and you've asked for two minutes uh
thank you members of the committee for
uh giving me your time and for being
here on uh Valentine's Day I appreciate
it um so this is an issue that's really
important to me um I I do like taking
part of the political process here in
New Hampshire but there aren't many
bills that have affected uh me
personally or friends that I have
personally I'd say that this is one of
the only ones so I decided today that I
would tell you a story about my friend
his name was Daniel um
he he was diagnosed as uh suffering from
diabetes um and he uh was able to
survive with it for uh quite a while he
received treatment um but he was on the
uh donor list for ages um because there
there weren't any donor matches uh for
him and if you look at the uh the kidney
registry it's really long um and there's
a lot of people uh waiting for it um and
unfortunately um when covid happened uh
the um you know the medical system was
pressured and it it put those pressures
on um not just the supply of kidneys but
also so on the amount of uh medical
professionals that would be able to
facilitate these operations so um so the
list got longer and longer and then they
changed the requirements to make it so
that um if you weren't vaccinated for
covid you would automatically be be
taken off the list um this this was a um
Daniel was a um person who um had very
strict religious beliefs about um
vaccines he he he didn't want to put his
um Health further in Jeopardy than it
already was so he opted out of it and
was removed from the list um he thought
about maybe going out of the country to
see if he could um you know purchase a
kidney because his life was in Jeopardy
but he realized that the moral and legal
implications of that would be too much
for him um he didn't want to um you know
do a shady Market deal where he's trying
to get um somebody's kidney even if he
thought like okay this person's a total
totally willing participant um he just
didn't feel morally comfortable doing
that um and so unfortunately he passed
away um he was somebody that loved to do
poetry he um he was loved by members of
his community he had a family um he he
didn't have a lot of money so um the
community actually
um crowdfunded a a wonderful funeral
service for him um and and I I think
that if this bill or a variation of it I
mean you're the committee members if you
want to change it to make it more in
line to something that's regulated or or
removing lines of code I I think that
that would be fair um but I I believe
that if there was a framework in place
um for a willing participant like me for
example to have um given him my kidney
for compensation like that I I think
he'd probably still be alive today and I
know that there are lots of examples of
of people like this it's it's not just
Daniel there's there's tons of people
that are affected by diabetes and uh and
kidneys are just one example um like
like the uh uh State red mentioned um
there there's people that are in chronic
need of of of blood as well um and I
think that we shouldn't put barriers
between someone being compensated to
save a life that I think that that's
what it comes down to um I'm willing to
take any questions any
questions representative Lon um thank
you Mr chairman and thank you for being
here and I'm so sorry for the loss of
your friend um we had passed a bill
previously about not discriminating
about vaccine status for healthcare um
would you mind sharing when your friend
was removed from the registry yeah um it
was a couple years ago I'd say that it
was maybe like about a a year after the
um vaccines were rolled out um if if you
want I emailed everybody on the
committee including um you so if you
want I could reach out to you later and
provide you an exact date that he was
denied I would appreciate that because
it seems that sometimes we pass laws
that don't actually um have an impact so
um it would be unfortunate if he simply
was not not within the time frame but it
would be an even more even more of a
travesty if he should have been
protected and he wasn't yeah I mean and
he did live in uh New Hampshire he lived
in Manchester so I think that he would
be protected by this if if it was in
effect at the time
sorry other
questions seeing D thank you thank
you also signed up to speak is Peter
Moren from New Hampshire do R Directors
Association and you've asked for five
minutes sir if you keep it to three
that'd be great I will make do my best
to even do make it shorter thank you uh
thank you chairman McDonald and thank
you members of the committee you've all
been here way way too long I appreciate
your service and and your your patience
um yes I'm Peter Moren um I'm Excuse me
uh I'm here uh representing the as the
executive director representing the New
Hampshire Funeral Directors Association
some of you have seen me before for um
and I'm also licensed funeral director
in Balmer here in New Hampshire I'm here
uh to uh before you today to uh in
opposition to this
bill the various things that that raised
concerns when I first read this uh my
first concern was why and you know it's
a purpose the the sponsor addressed that
but of course I always kind of look at
the big picture and as to what could
could go wrong and this is kind of a
very broad a broad interpretation of
this bill I I respect his his position
and his so for I'm a
uh believer in in U you know personal
freedom and and those things Our concern
is of the of Public Health and Welfare
uh and also ethical issues of handling
and the disposition of these body parts
and fluids it's the representative from
the New Hampshire Oregon Bank who we
work very closely with in Funeral
Service uh in terms of donors when it
comes to organs no those are done in the
O and the hospital but when it comes to
other tissues and Don and and uh other
tissues and corneas uh they're often
those things are often harvested or
retrieved in the funeral home and I also
have to point out that uh in my uh
anatomical education uh in mortuary
school is that skin is the L largest
organ in the body okay so if we're
talking organs we're talking talking
skin of course they do uh do that for
tissue donors for burn victims and and
in other cases like that um and you know
we have people what we've had in in the
country in the last several years is not
so much in the Northeast but we've
seeing it more and more across the
country particularly in the Southwest is
we have uh basically unlicensed
thirdparty providers who are offering on
billboards uh free cremation if you
donate your loved On's body for medical
science what happens in these cases and
this I won't get too graphic is the
family comes they're bed but this they
may not have that that $500 or ,000 or
more that they would need for that
cremation this is a very attractive
offer and so they sign documents that
they have no idea they're signing and
basically what they're doing is they're
turning their loved ones body over to
these individuals who then take that
body and quite frankly part it out and
it is used yes for medical research and
other things it's been some cases where
they have been used for ballistic tests
with the
military um and and other instances like
that and what happens is the parties the
parts are either sold or leased and they
can be leased over and over again or
resold there is no act no ability of
tracking this at all um and eventually
uh those B those body the parts never
come back to the family I'm not sure
what they're given in return as far as
cremated remains uh but the the fact
that they're told that that's what
they'll they'll receive is is is
blatantly false what we're doing right
now currently on a national level we
we're involved very close with the
national Funeral Directors Association
as are all of the other State uh funeral
direct funeral associations we've been
working on this bill uh and I'll just
read it just I won't read the bill but
the title of the bill and I will send
you this give this information in my
testimony here which I have a copy for
each of you uh it's both in the Senate
and the house and this is the uh
consensual donation and research
Integrity Act of 2023 this is the third
Congress that we've introduced this
we're gaining traction it's getting more
appeal uh most of the times when I meet
our members here in New Hampshire are
all supporting this in both of their
houses um and of course uh we will be
able to monitor that under uh Federal
Regulations particularly when it comes
to interstate commerce that's the one
place that they can do it and so we've
got to find a way to Reign this in there
are people who are totally unscrupulous
and I'm not saying that that's the case
here but there's that possibility we
open it up and it's the kind of thing
that keeps me awake at night because you
know we deal with the families who are
going to be dealing with these people in
these situations when things don't work
out and I respect what the the uh
representative from the Oregon Bank made
uh about the idea of indiv individuals
perhaps being coerced we're concerned
about the
deceased uh their their human remains
because this bill doesn't specify is it
the living or the or the dead and who
sells these parts and families nowadays
you know if they felt they could I'm not
saying they're all like this but there
are those who could just see the dollar
value in their loved one what they might
be able to get if they could sell uh
sell body parts could start wrapping up
yes sir I uh I'll bring I'll close it
right up now and of course Rec more
recently um we just had last year uh
very close to home the instance with the
Harvard Medical School there morg uh
there morg and the operat the manager of
there morg uh had been selling body
parts around the country uh it was found
out that this happened least involved
eight anyway I think this been going for
much longer uh the courts just um
dismissed the civil cases against
Harvard and and their other people this
individual is still under Federal
indictment uh again under the interstate
commerce part because he was selling
them across state lines uh this
gentleman unfortunately for us was a was
is a resident of New Hampshire and so
you know we we that's not how we want to
make the national news and uh but he is
still under under uh invest
investigation he's still being tried for
that so so this this problem is closer
to home but I just think we need to
regulate this and make sure there's a
there's a lot more work that needs to go
into this if we're going to do this and
I have to I have to uh you know
certainly uh bow to to the medical uh
individuals and the doctors and so forth
and this thank you thank you any
question there any
questions seeing no questions thank
you no one else has signed up to speak
on this bill um four people did uh
excuse me five people did sign up on the
blue sheet in the back one indicating
they were in favor four people
indicating they were opposed online now
last we we checked and 19 signed up in
support 16 signed up in
opposition uh that is the last bill for
us to consider today so I'm going to
close the public hearing on HB
1482 I we'll be reconvening tomorrow
morning uh for additional hearings at
10:00 a.m. thank you all for being here
and we stand adjourned